hey welcome everybody I am so excited
for my special guest that came up she's
actually produces a majority of her
stuff from England but she's back
visiting family in Chicago so she came
up uh to come spend some time up in
Green Bay Wisconsin I even ask you have
you been up here before no no I didn't
even know where I was coming today
that's awesome
I want everybody to welcome uh Pearl uh
from pearly things she's got one of my
favorite YouTube channels and it's an
honor to have here today yeah thank you
for having me I love it here yeah thank
you so um Pearl here's what happens is
you know I know quite a bit about you
and I'm excited to actually bring you on
because as you know that the majority of
my audience obviously is women watching
things and and we've always had a
different perspective when it came to
males and females and then when your
stuff started to come out
um it caught my attention really quickly
because the stuff that you were saying
and but we really don't want my audience
to know is you know you know tell us a
little bit about about Pearl and I got
and I've got so many questions for you
today I'm going to run through a lot of
things that way but once you tell tell
everybody who Pearl is well
most of my
Chicago suburbs nine siblings parents
owned a software company Me growing Up
um and about one two years ago I just
started researching the history of
feminism and all of the propaganda and
the lies that they used to basically
in a way manipulate women because we're
just you know they can just convince us
of anything and
um and yeah and I basically I started a
YouTube channel where I would show my
friends this information so I would find
out oh the pay Gap isn't real like
they've told us that we're making less
because we're women and the whole time
it was just because we worked Less hours
like that actually makes perfect sense
and or the industries we picked that
makes perfect sense so I would bring a
friend who'd been indoctrinated by
feminism and I'd say hey let's sit down
we're gonna watch this like three hour
piece of content and just talk about it
and it would just be me like red pilling
my friends in real time and that sort of
evolved to a show and it's funny because
I was
um actually recruited to England so I
live in England now and I was recruited
there to play volleyball so it started
and I played basketball too and I would
I would bring my friend who was on the
basketball team back and I would recruit
like athletes so I started my show it's
called the pregame and it was the
pre-game because one we were all
athletes and I always liked like I
always felt like before the in college
you'd go to a party right and before the
party started like you would have the
best conversations with your friends but
it was just like your intimate close
group of friends and you would talk
about this stuff you know maybe not
feminism in particular but you talk
about men and women relationships and
really what I realized was that feminism
was just ruining relationships and that
it basically was telling women that
we're equal to men but even in a
household that doesn't work right and
most of us had gone our whole lives
never having heard the words you should
obey your husband right well by far in
today's world that's actually frowned
upon yeah so so I actually answered the
second question I said well did the idea
of pearly things came from it came from
sharing from the friends the stuff you
were learning which led to my third
question because you already said this
okay you know and obviously the audience
that watches you understands it and I
think a lot of my life says too but
you've defined it well so when you
talked about you said listen that
they've been red pilled can you explain
what you mean by that and obviously you
know some of the people watching do you
understand that but I want you to
explain that and what you're trying to
accomplish by showing people that well
well I people use the term red pill in
so many different ways but when I say it
it's like you're finding out how the
world really is so I'll give you an
example when you get red pilled on
feminism you find out that the early
suffragettes that are painted as these
women that were just fighting for us
women to get the rights that we so
desperately needed
um actually were hated they weren't
liked by the women at the time and they
were always just crazy ladies that they
even planned assassinations they were
thrown in jail constantly and they were
bailed out by this one divorcee chick
that just wanted everyone else to be Miz
I forgot her name but like there was a
divorce say like one of the first
divorces in the 1800s literally this
chick divorced her husband and then
married his friend and then divorced him
too so it was like the OG feminists
taking half
that this has caused like men and women
aren't together like women are
completely lied to and there's all of
these institutions where like honestly
everyone's just confused
um so when I say red pilled I mean it's
showing
it's it's seeing the world how it is not
how we're taught it is and I think one
things that I I think that people have
to understand about you and I think
you've done a really good job of this is
because a lot of day times you'll see
um more conservative people more
Christian people talk about feminism in
a negative way okay but you even related
back to its beginning so people say you
know I'm I'm I'm an old feminist mean in
fact I'm fighting for women's rights
that's why I want you to go on to say I
want you to go so I want you I want you
to give me the difference between the
modern day feminism to the to its
relationship back when it first started
and he gave a good example of a runner
today that I would like you to run on
that way but so so my question is do you
believe feminism is a good thing the bad
thing and was it ever a good thing no I
don't think I think that's the biggest
misconception that's like the way they
lie to us is they they try to Rebrand
early feminism as a good thing but they
were not liked they were like how could
it be a good thing if we were planning
assassination but it's really just it's
it's lying to women because it's telling
us that we are are equal to men how are
we equal to men if we cannot do what men
do right the example I gave you what
earlier was we were talking about the
marathon yes and the Boston Marathon
right well it was the Boston Marathon
the Boston Marathon is really
competitive you have to qualify to be in
it and women just didn't want to run
26.2 my I've run a marathon and that was
the worst day of my life it was a
horrible day I was like I found I hate
feminism for convincing me I should do
this but
um so basically this woman ran in the
men's race okay and it's so funny
because when the men run in women's
races everyone's freaking out it's on
the cover of the news but when a woman
runs in a man's race she's applauded and
rewarded and told she's breaking this
glass ceiling when that chick is
actually just entitled because she could
have ran her she could have started her
own race but she just demanded I must be
allowed into this race and all the
reporters were like waiting for her at
the end to finish because she was so
slow
and so so but basically there was a
picture that went viral of her like
being held back by the tournament
director because she was running her
race and the tournament director was
like nah get out of here chick he's like
trying to pull her off and her I mean
this is like the OG simp like her
boyfriend was like no no no he's like a
boxer or something so all right now the
the guy doesn't want to get beat up you
know what I mean this woman goes on to
have no kid she's a two-time divorcee
the the woman that ran the marathon and
she was convincing more women to run
marathons which I don't know if that
can't be good for us I'm sorry I ran one
and that was just the worst I have ever
felt in my life it's funny you say that
because you're right and that story I
did look it up it's like they they look
at her like a hero correct when she was
entitled yes in the top it's funny
because I love the relationship you just
made there is that right now
um man you're actually gonna make both
sides upset with that kind of example
which I absolutely love because you're
talking about that right now that if a
woman steps into a man's world it's
applauding on conservative sites correct
it's like conservatives are feminists
they just don't know it yes a lot of
them a lot it's really sad it's sad okay
do me a favor I want you guys to quote
that because see I don't uh that's one
thing that I've always said I don't I
don't subside to any political party or
any definition or a tribe that way
because that's right so let's put that
quote on Pearl said that concern say it
again conservatives are feminists they
just don't know it there we go I want
that quote I want that put up there I
want that that's a fantastic quote that
way because you're right because it that
person even on all circles or look like
well she's a hero well you know it's a
really funny thing to talk about that
way um I'm a golfer okay and and it's
interesting because all sudden when
Michelle we tried to say that she could
play with the boys play the men and she
just got destroyed I mean and they and
they even look at the LPGA which
actually makes no money and stuff of
that it's like it's funded by the PGA
and you see a lot of these girls
complaining about that they don't get
sponsorships it's because you don't sell
product you don't you make no money but
the idea is this is like every Power
four shorter every par three shorter
every you just if they if they played on
the the average course of what the guy
did they would never they could never
even compete even if you were the best
girl golfer and stuff and so it's like
but it's really interesting but they I
you're right I did see people say you go
girl it's like well no or it's like what
happened at the the Masters Tournament
where the the club was all men they they
had to infiltrate it with women even
conservative people are like but why why
can't guys just have their own thing and
why can't women just have their own
thing yeah and I realized too that men
act differently when women are around
well I do like crazy yeah it was guys
Dean that's what and I wanna I wanna ask
let's just question that's why it's like
you hear even and it drives me nuts
Christian people and conservative people
saying you know you should tell
everything to your spouse and everything
to your wife I'm like no you should not
no no freaking
friend like that that's feminism because
you're implying like that you guys are
equal or when they say this is my
partner that's feminine like they
Infiltrate The feminists infiltrate our
language even like shady the and that
was in the early late 1800s early 1900s
um they I can't remember which family it
was but they realized they would have
more influence by infiltrating the
churches and they actually so far so
they wanted to rewrite the Bible and
you'll see non-denominational churches
are the worst because because I've
preached that for years and it's not
because I'm like anti like a lot of
people think I'm anti-church or
Christianity it's not it's not true but
it's it's because they're not
centralized so like if a cat in Catholic
Church of churches have gone off the
rails too but we're a little delayed
because the Christian churches go first
because like if one Christian church
starts to go off the rails like the
because they're decentralized nobody's
gonna check them but where the Catholic
churches if one goes too bad or the
Orthodox those seem to be the like ones
that are the least but they're they're
still and there's even um I think they
said like ten thousand priests into like
they they funded seminary schools to get
us to so it's not like we're but they
weaponized the Bible too and then they
misquote it and I'm not even like a
die-hard like religious part but I know
when I hear it so when they're
like you need to submit to each other
you need to like it's just nonsense and
whenever you you disrupt the natural
order of the world which is supposed to
be God God I mean argue some people
think government's in it some don't but
God government men women women are below
men and I literally I couldn't think of
one thing that women are better at
because like I'm like when we're single
mothers like we do terrible jobs so if
we're better parents on our own then why
aren't our kids better and then I found
out we're more likely to kill the
infants and the elderly and I'm like
we're more nurturing but I realize we're
only our best selves under the authority
of men that's when we can be our
greatest selves but we literally can't
be unless we're under a man's Authority
right and that and that that's why
sometimes people I I I find so funny
because when I I when you interviewed me
on your page and then what happened is
then I post like crazy you would see it
was never the men that were attacking
you oh women there's always women and I
was like going oh my goodness I was like
and that's why I found it it's kind of
so funny is is I said this right next
it's like who do you find is your
biggest fans and who are your biggest
haters
[Music]
um
I found my fans the biggest fans are
actually men that grew up in single
mother homes because a lot of this stuff
it's like they've almost gone their
whole lives like never having like heard
this stuff right and never having like a
chick like agree with this you know
um I'd say my biggest haters are
and I would say men also that run the
infrastructure of society so like I
don't know building Builder like you
know construction workers that sort of
thing
um the for the women
that are the biggest haters I would say
fat chicks yeah the fat chicks can't
stand me because I think we should be
bullied a little bit you know what I
mean like I think a little bullying is
is good for you know I was like almost
210 to 20 pounds at one point and you
know what made me lose weight you know I
ran a marathon yeah well not me but
these guys at the office were talk about
how they never would date a chick over
200 pounds and they didn't know I was
six I'm tall so I hide it well right
right and um I had a crush on one of the
guys at the office
but
[Laughter]
um yeah I think bullying is good for you
I think it shows you care yeah well
yeah I would tell people you know don't
get rid of your haters because you know
something sometimes the haters actually
can you know see some things that you're
missing and we think that if we said
anything bad to somebody that way and
their feelings are hurt it's just you
know devastating to their whole life I
mean people you know people especially
with you know guys today so if you look
at this way
um why do women consider then you know I
watch you know I'll pop on YouTube and
then I'll I'll I love I love the content
but I love watching the comments and
that was the best you know Sam and it's
like it's like uh um Pearl you're
anti-woman you saying no it's hilarious
so so what do you say when people say
that you're anti well if anything I'm
Pro I'm pro-reality and it's just we
have lived our whole life as women just
not being in reality because the men lie
to us the government lies to us and
institutions lie to us and I just think
life is better when you live in reality
especially when you learn it when you're
younger like I had a tweet that got 10 I
think 10 to 15 million views or I said
25 year old chicks are hotter than 35
year old chicks yeah and this was
controversial and I'm like they used to
call you a leftover woman at like 27.
and you were shamed now the average age
of first marriage is like 31 in the UK
which like we can have a cultural shift
but that doesn't change our biology I've
seen studies where men will smell like
women like they'll give men like scents
and they'll still pick the younger
chicks and then I'm being told I'm like
I'm encouraging like pedophilia that I'm
I'm like what this is like basic
knowledge that if we asked our great
grandmothers do you get uglier the older
they get they'd say women Yes Men age
like wine there's a reason that we have
these phrases but it's like like and I'm
thinking like if we lived in this
delusion that we're gonna be the hottest
versions of ourselves by 50. does that
help us women is that is that like and
that's what I'm saying like it might not
be nice but I would just rather live in
like reality
now speaking of that because there's
some things you've done on your your
page that were great too if you think
about this then let's say that there is
there is a shelf life the beauty there
is and and I think that we see that a
lot of these young women today and I
want to get your opinion on this because
some of the most you know let's say
attractive ages are when women are in
college oh yeah so what do you think
about the Samaritan college girls drink
so much in college that it's before yes
like honestly like I mean you know like
the it's like probably like 18 because
like the Freshman 15 happens everyone's
a fatty by like 20. it's like literally
I I found out by 25 it's like 70 of us
are overweight or 60 yeah I'm like this
is terrible we're doing terrible so
late's there the amount of sexual
partners yeah you know I I think I
watched your show one time he said the
average was like almost 20 during their
their college Years well okay this is
the problem the studies women limited
like 70 of women admit to lying about
their like sexual history so the stats
are so unreliable but there's some stats
that let's say girls average
um seven Partners in a year per semester
or per like year in college there's some
like that say like the average body
count is between five and eight it
doesn't really matter because honestly
at the biggest drop for like marital
satisfaction is two and really at five
you're kind of done like you really only
have a 20 chance of a happy marriage so
it's like I mean these these stats
aren't fun they're not nice I'm not
saying there's zero hope but it's like
would we rather live in reality or live
in delusion right you know and the CH
and the the truth of the matter is
there's there are consequences for your
choices and Men know this they're like
okay if I go to prison
that might affect me in the future but
women are like I can sell my body and
only fans and I will find love later and
I'm like well
I I hope you do but you know I think
reality hurts in the short term but it
like helps in the long term so you
interview a lot of women on your show
and other than that and I watch their
reactions to when you talk about what
males really value I want to say this
and it's very important males really
value three things we're looking for a
mate okay Beauty Purity and youth that's
it that's it it's like and so it's like
and uh um and these girls they really
come at you hard
you know and and what why does that seem
why does it seem to trigger women so
much when the guys every guy says yep
look at every guy's like shaking hands
I'll tell you what one problem is the
sympademic because men want to get laid
and so it's like you know they'll
they'll come out like I've had this on
my show where the guys would be like I
don't care about a girl's body count and
I just look at him I'm like why are you
lying right like you're like but it's
like because he wants to add to it you
know what I mean yeah so part of it is
we're confused because like guys you
know that women are attracted to will
will will tell them things that are not
true because they want to get laid right
but the other part of it is if you're
not it you're gonna get mad you're
telling me a 21 year old virgin
beautiful chick is going to be offended
when I say men like Purity youth like
yeah like she's like hotness if she's in
shape and a virgin it's like she'll be
like yeah probably yeah yeah and women
know the sudden innate level because no
one shames more than women do to
other women I'm sorry if we hate a chick
if our ex-boyfriend is dating a chick
that we don't like and we are are the
first to call her a hoe that's it that's
their biggest ones to do man A lot of
times they're like all right the
marketplace sucks 96 percent of women
aren't virgins so I'd rather just not
know but it's funny because the other
women like throw each other on here well
it's funny it's the most derogatory
thing another woman called another woman
is based on a body count Jamie you
know saying and it's like yet it's it's
it's it's propagating a culture today
that that's what you know that that's an
acceptable thing and the sad part is
this it's like uh now that being said I
want to bring up something because I
stole this from you okay because it was
really funny because
um I was you know I've always talked
about like you said you know males have
an attraction to you know peer tributes
and Purity uh um Youth and beauty and
what happens is but today and you got in
trouble on what the social media
platforms because this woman was
attacking you and you said well you're
just a whale you're saying and and it
was insane because here's what happens
and use the example and it's really
interesting it's like if all of a sudden
a woman doesn't take care of herself and
she jumps around you're talking about
lizzo it's like it's almost applauded
yet guys behind his closed doors I'm
I've never I've never held them like
going fat do something about it I think
I think guys just from my experience
an absolute horror that's hot over a fat
chick
it's like the best
yet as a person purse trainer yes yeah
yes oh my goodness the guys are like
look I'll adapt all right like like 96
of women aren't virgins on their wedding
day so men really a hundred years ago 85
percent of women were yep I mean let's
just say they were lying and it's 30 but
okay that's still two out of three this
is how much men have adapted but they
will not stand for fat chicks they are
like that that is the line I'll take
anything uh-huh and that's and I think
that's why they had to normalize it I
think because what happens is guys got
sick of it but today it's like going you
know we don't find it attractive and I
actually you know this is going to
offend a lot of people I've never told
you this so my daughters and I were
shopping and my young daughters and we
went through we're getting some things
and we walked by Victoria's Secret and
walk by the pink store and usually they
always had beautiful pictures of
beautiful girls there now it's Fat Boy
and I looked at my daughters and said
listen this is wrong this is not
attractive we do not find this
attractive I'm teaching my 10 year old
my 14 year old my 16 year old say listen
I said this is something we do not find
attractive so do not love it I sent off
it look at all Healthcare conditions
that come from that because you know
that every Healthcare condition every
Healthcare condition from RT's cancer
diet all of them are accelerated by
obesity so how can we say that that is
something that we want to see our women
live yeah and the reason I called that
chick a whale was because she called me
a slag first my leg Yeah yeah so I was
doing Street interviews yes and then
this chick
um I was
what was it we were arguing because she
oh she was mad because she was saying oh
I can't walk home alone at night and
it's always the ugly chicks complaining
about this and I'm like really I think
you'll be okay
like I'm not like trying to be an
but I'm like maybe the hotties
over there might have problems you're
fine you're fine but so she's like
knocking the mic out of my hand and
trying to attack me and calling me a
slag so I'm like well you're a whale
like if you're gonna like let's just so
she was disrespectful and then you call
her something that way yeah you're a bad
person yeah well and you know honestly I
think I was disrespectful to the whales
in the sea
no yeah they started the whales always
started now now think about this so but
but why do the why do the whales why the
fat chicks why the ugly chicks have more
confidence say than they did 50 years
ago 40 years ago and 30 years ago oh
because that all the chicks are uglier
today it's so crazy you look at a film
from like 30 years just 30 years ago
gosh it's like one the women had so much
more of like a natural beauty like so
much less work done everyone looks like
a Bratz doll but but it's like and like
they're all like so skinny and I'm just
like wow like now everyone's worse so
it's like like even most American women
would do so we would be humbled so quick
so quick even in Germany I went to a
German wedding and don't get me wrong
like feminism's there too but they're
not as fat right and I'm like in Asia
we've got we would be humble we would
get no male attention right but it's
like I know there's studies that
indicate sex is a need for men so it's
like if everyone sucks you don't realize
that we're below average right because
everyone's so bad go ahead so you think
that then
I see this a lot do you think that
because of the worldwide attention that
even
women that are not holding themselves to
standards of beauty Purity and youth
um they just have much more to pick from
because there is always these guys that
are willing to you know not become
themselves and I think I see a lot I
think that the the downgrade of men has
allowed that to happen because if you're
not taking care of your mind muscle
money I called three M's I think my guy
asks me I always take care is my muscle
money has to look apart do a part and
therefore obviously that has been
downgraded because they attack on them
but they're opposition so they're going
to put up with you know
that kind of situation because they
actually haven't put themselves to the
standard there but then what do you
think the way you think the influence of
social media has had on that oh it's oh
it's horrible it's like called hoflation
hopefully well think about it throughout
history the top like 15 percent of men
have not been monogamous right women
would rather be the king's concubine
than the peasant's wife typically they
always talk about you have a dominant
you had a dominant guy it's like he
could provide for 10 women yeah he had
10 women he he absolutely does because
you're that or die correct and so what
social media has done has given all
these chicks access to the Kings and so
obviously now the The Peasant gets the
king's leftovers
so It's like because we normally
wouldn't have access to these guys that
is true and actually Aaron and Miranda
Miranda Runza she's the ones to actually
start my Instagram you'd be surprised
what people send me on Instagram
you'd be women what they said oh yeah
I'm like and Miranda's like uh yeah look
at the face and Ran's like uh Delete
delete It's like because they know I
have money they know I've been
successful they know this they know we
know keep those three M's up by the way
it's really funny it's like that's why I
said they're going oh my goodness I'm
like going you know this is the and
there's not a suspect today that women
are being that aggressive now today oh
yeah it's kind of crazy and it's like
you know it's uh you I was so surprised
by the fact on social media that way and
then but don't you also think on the
flip side that it because of the amount
of lonely men out there that it makes
that person that woman that isn't you
know I always say listen women need
three s's sexy supportive and serenity
you're saying they bring those three
things to a man they've got them he's
saying you can take a king guess what
happens you give them support you give
you keep yourself sexy you're Serenity
and that brings peace to a guy guess
what happens I mean you're gonna you're
gonna keep him forever you're gonna win
his heart like crazy and um but the but
the thing about this say is
there would you would you say that the
women haven't held themselves up to
those kind of Standards like I'm saying
men should stand to it but they so
they'll always have enough guys reaching
out to them because the social media
platforms you could live in northern
Wisconsin where before you just married
the local guy yeah but now you can get a
message from somebody in California
and it opens up your dating pool like
crazy yeah and so it's like so I think
that that's that's given us that's given
you know women more options to where
it's like uh it's leave it's left the
guys that are not going to you know work
on themselves greatly which once again I
don't think that they deserve anything
if they're not putting themselves out
there in a great way so then where do
you see that so then were you surprised
that when you actually started to share
with your friends and share with the
public that way the response you got
yeah I mean
I mean yes and no I always knew that
Morgan because I would say like before I
I started going into more of like men's
specific content I would have been more
of like a Trad con you know like the
traditional like Ben Shapiro tell like
that's what I kind of consumed before
but so I knew like there's a visceral
reaction but I think the the biggest
surprise for me was the lack of empathy
for men because I'm doing a documentary
right yeah so I'm doing a documentary
about divorce court and I just could not
believe the lack of empathy that they
had for men that could not get access to
their kids like even on public platforms
a man will lose half of his wealth not
get access to his children and the Trad
cons would and the left would come in
and say well that's his fault for
picking the wrong chick and I'm like
like all right so if a woman picked a
guy and got left after she had five kids
for him we're we're gonna just say oh
it's your fault for picking the wrong
now I don't I I there's some truth to
that but what was more my observation
was like wow there's such a lack of
empathy when it comes to men from men
and women it just seems like you know
and I think that's why women have so
much power today is because men are
naturally benevolent towards women and
women are naturally benevolent towards
women but men and women are not
benevolent towards like men especially
men like women don't find attractive
right yeah well what's what's the stats
did you talk about showing the
guy blowed one out of three guys below
the age of 30 aren't having sex yeah
their virgins are haven't had sex in the
past year right and that's why they you
know run towards things that they
shouldn't and things of that so it's
like yeah we have more we have more male
virgins than female virgins Now isn't
that crazy that when I read that stat
after you put that I'm like oh my gosh I
gotta look this up and I was like Wow
and stuff now here's what happens though
so what would you after interviewing and
spending time talking all these people
that what'd you contribute to would you
say so yeah
I can honestly say I think I'm on the
flip side being the male is because I
agree with everything you say except
there's one thing that I've been sitting
there going
you know you know this because people
say well you know the old statue on a
guy that's six foot making six figures
and stuff like that but yourself is this
if you have your mind muscle money
together I think as a as a guy I don't
care what your age group is if you have
those three things together you're going
to attract a certain woman oh yeah
and I think that so but I think that now
has been you've been discouraged well
I'll tell you I think the problem
a good woman well I do but but here's
the here's the problem one there's no
guarantee even if you find a virgin
chick you don't know if she's telling
the truth and now it's a lot easier for
women with dating apps with Instagram
it's a lot easier for women to hide that
stuff right and the second thing is
women were so easy to propagate it's
like your chick gets around I'll talk to
men that had a chick that like she was
young she she you know was more from a
more traditional culture had everything
but she gets around divorced friends and
then leaves her husband she gets around
she gets on social media and starts
scrolling like it actually blew my mind
the more I studied this how we're just
kind of like big kids that'll believe
anything I don't know what it is it's
like you show women like a video of like
a 12 year old not getting an abortion
and not being able to get an abortion of
her rapist and we just run to the polls
we're like oh my God we need to go fix
like and it's like
I don't know so I think the problem now
with social media is in play and even if
you get a good woman if she gets like
we're so easy to propagate that we go to
the institutions we're propagated we go
on TV we're propagated that in a way it
there's no way for a man to completely
avoid the risk yep well I want to add
something to us yeah and we haven't
talked about this yet you know you talk
about that uh um
that they're that they get involved with
their friends that are divorcing that I
want you to do this I've noticed this a
lot especially over the last couple
years churches are just as big as a
problem
because I've said this before churches
and and hearing that and I've learned
this and I've talked to a lot of men
that have women that are very you know
mouthy and it's always these Church
women a lot of them because because the
pastors lead in the in the as I said and
I said no remember let me say this I am
a little bit more let's say religious
that way I would consider myself a
Christian person love Jesus with all my
heart things of that so I don't want to
confuse people when they talk when they
see this because I like going Innocent
but I am anti-church more than you ever
believe because majority of pastors are
are a bunch of feminists they really are
and they're empowering women to they say
to a point where they're de-masculine
men and and then here watch this and
I've came up with this I want you to
think of this if the remember you like
you said the woman is supposed to look
at the man's leadership do you
understand that even these Christian
couples the
the woman looks more at the church or
the pastor as a leader than the husband
and and and she'll be like and then what
she'll do is she she'll relegate
propaganda to the husband like he's
supposed to be following that I was like
shut up shut the hell up you're not in
most pastors I tell you now the church I
left his daughter is a divorced my
best friend and stuff like that she was
a drunk their son lives off of uh lives
off their dad and off the money pays him
a hundred thousand dollar salary to play
guitar on a Saturday around Sunday he's
saying it's like going I was like going
you're right so it's you got to be
careful who women are around well and
and especially the church I have a joke
this is a joke so this is
tongue-in-cheek don't take this serious
that that the church is a homemaking
machine because what they'll do is
they'll bring you in these Chastity
speakers of these born-again chicks and
it's like and it's like attention and
attention to women is like currency so
it's like now she gets this career where
she gets to talk about her passion is
that yeah it's like oh I used to be a
hoe when I got married so it's like now
you're telling the chicks you can do
whatever you want and you can just say
sorry and you're good there's no
consequences and you get to be a hero in
the church and you get to go tell all
these other women and it's like so funny
to me and I sit there and I'm just like
huh and then and then the funny thing is
the pastors half the time are the ones
screwing up
so and then the men are like let's go to
church this is where the hoes are at
well on top of it and then so then you
get all these like damaged women just
coming to church and it's like like it's
a lot harder to fix it she like to fix a
chick and I'm not saying nobody can be
fixed yes but it's a lot harder it's a
lot easier to just like tell the Next
Generation learn from them well it's
funny because I actually have a question
for you you're gonna love this one okay
okay
um because it's I watch this argument
happening show every time can you make a
whole housewife
well
I mean to be fair I'd say 90 of how the
housewives today
hundreds because really if you had more
than one partner from a historical point
of view you'd be outcast right you were
gone you were done so I guess the answer
is men do every day it's not gonna stop
they probably will continue but there's
a reason there's a 50 divorce rate right
so not well
yeah so you'd started you started some
things
um on your channel stuff like that about
um teaching women how to be a wife do
you think that's happening a lot today
no and I'd like to say I don't teach
anyone how to be a wife I bring on wives
and I yeah
um no I think it's so funny when I
started to realize all the institutions
I went to were like started and run by
feminists like college is completely a
feminist institution where like it would
be one thing if you went to college to
support your husband's career yep but we
don't we go to college for our own
careers and now we're starting to
outpace like men in college and it's
also interesting too because volleyball
like that's that's a feminist
institution because like if you're a
traditional woman like a true tradcon
you spend your primary reproductive
years like the best when you have the
most Purity the most youth all that
stuff on your family because family
comes before anything for yourself but
what we do is all these institutions are
pushing women to spend their MO their
primary reproductive years on themselves
and it doesn't make us like when you
think of a family you have to be
selfless it teaches us to like and then
you have all these resentful wives of
like giving up their career because they
felt like they were supposed to have one
yep well you're going to see a lot of
single non
um married no kids people are 45 years
old that may have money in the bank but
they're lonely as can be yeah you know
and um that's something I think that
they're they're in November I employ a
lot of women and I always tell and
actually employ a lot of women doctors
too and I said listen I say don't give
up those years to when you're most
fertile you're most I understand that
you want to have a career but you know
it's really funny I said this the other
day it's um you know my grandma died you
know at 94 Christy's grandma died in 95
I think it was and stuff with that 94
okay too so both the grandmas died one
of our grandsons at 94 and 94 and stuff
and it was interesting because you know
at the funeral at both funerals you know
it's really funny it was like um that
woman's gonna be known for the Legacy
and the the life that she gave and
there's Generations sitting there you're
saying and the dad's gonna the Grandpa's
gonna be known did he provide for that
family you know and I think that you're
gonna see a generation with all the
stuff where women are so involved in
their careers that they're going to be
like they're going to be their legacy
they're not meant to create the Legacy I
want to tell you the biggest red pill I
realized daddy issues aren't real okay
they're mommy issues it's mothers
imposing their will on the family 90 of
the time all these deadbeat dads they're
not deadbeat dads that most of the time
it's women that are using their kids as
a weapon against the father I think that
God is in men this is this is just a
thought that I have I think God is
naturally in men and the devil is
naturally in women because when women
are left to our own devices we just
we're crazy like like think about it
we've had more Choice the last hundred
years than ever it's gotten worse and we
have been horrible with it nine ninety
percent of us have been on birth control
the average body count is five to eight
and nobody believes that so it's
probably way higher right it's like the
average chick gets married at 31 the
average chick has two kids which is
below the replacement rate like and so
it's like when when we have all this
choice we don't choose well so and like
what happened when I started thinking
about like the creation story and I was
thinking about how what was the biggest
like what what happened Adam listened to
his wife they're not supposed to listen
to us because the devil I think works
through women and I think that's why
they gave women the right to vote was
because they realized that women can be
convinced of damn near anything and it's
myself too like people act like I say oh
I'm so much better than chicks no no no
no like like I'll I'll you know I'll
hear some horoscopes and I'm like oh
maybe horoscopes
but you know there's always sugars no no
there's a reason we go with the latest
fashion trends there's a reason we
believe we pick our husbands off of
horoscope signs like if we don't have
male guidance and male leadership
goes awry so usually when there's daddy
issues It's usually the mom talking
about the dad for years women do this
it's so common even in two parent
households like and the worst thing they
did the feminist was make a contract
where the marriage contract basically if
the woman leaves she gets everything the
man leaves he loses it everything so now
we have a contract where the man is
always going to try to make the woman
happy and what do we know about women I
mean Tom Brady just got divorced right
Tom Brady it's like we are never happy
right I mean especially like the modern
chick I know there's like this isn't all
right but I'm just saying as a group so
it's like now he's like basically a
slave to his wife and now we have
phrases called happy wife happy life
it's cheaper to keep her right and it's
like we have these phrases for a reason
like and it's basically like men are
just stuck to a lot of times these Witch
of women and they don't wanna and men
men care a lot more about honor than
women it's actually really sad like I
was thinking about this because men it's
like we'll stay with a fat chick that
doesn't sleep with them for years
because they care so much about the kids
we're women like I think in the 90s when
the divorce started taking off one of
the number one reasons was like women
finding themselves or something like
that it was some really vague reason and
I'm like so you're gonna put your kid at
every statistical disadvantage to be
happy like this is but again I think God
is naturally in men because you guys
have like you naturally have honor you
naturally have like respect and it's so
funny because when women get power we
tend to police men and they'll be
disrespectful majorly disrespectful yeah
where it's funny when men get power you
guys will police each other it's so
funny like like if a guy like if a guy
gets out a lie and like like that's how
you guys are able to build civilizations
if some guys were getting too crazy they
jail them beat them up or shoot them
like like men understand this but women
it's like based on how we feel you know
women are more likely to wage war yes
yes the last 500 years the queens and
queens have like a reputation for being
like like very brutal
um you know and I think it's because
women we get our periods one day and
then we're all angry it's like but I
think it's more honest when we
understand how we are and we can like
work with it and I got crucified because
I always said this when I start teaching
about female cycle and I'm actually very
empathetic that a woman's physical and
mental things change every week yeah
that means her decisions that means how
she sees the world that means everything
changes and so therefore I've always
said this and and I'm saying it's a joke
but I'm also saying tongue-in-cheek
where a woman's like well doc I feel
like I'm unstable you're not supposed to
be stable
but but I'm sorry I don't want that
instability making life the same
decisions for my family and things of
that and it's really funny it's like
it's and and then they act like you know
you know it's really interesting because
what they'll do is they're everybody
always talks about the exceptions about
the rules they talk about the women that
uh 100 years ago they were so suppressed
and that they had it so bad that women
are never happy before all this Freedom
that way am I going no you know what
happens is they put the story up there
of the abusive husband that but she goes
to this you don't surprise me with pearl
that still happens today you saying so
it's not like abuse hasn't gone away on
either side it's just that the fact that
it's like they they painted the mod the
the past women like the one that stayed
home and took care of the kids and she
was suppressed and just not happy
because she wasn't going in pursue in
her dreams well and it's not even true
you know there's writings in the early
1900s of men saying that the courts were
still unfair yes yeah like also women
killed their kids this abortion think
not new yes not new women like we kill
our kids like there's no tomorrow I
don't really understand it I don't know
why I think it's like because you got
pregnant by The Peasant when you wanted
the king you all you wanted the king
seed whatever it was but like women used
to kill arguably between like 10 to 20
percent of their kid you know it's it's
not all that got reported you know but
and they really were never prosecuted
and and this is like the abortion thing
it's like we do it before now but it's
like we used to so it's like this idea
that women are just these innocent
creatures men have always been
benevolent towards women if there was a
guy that was known for beating up his
wife you don't think the other guys
would have come and beat his ass exactly
oh my gosh like all the courts have
always been like you guys can't even
help it we just start crying and you
guys are like oh yeah but do you know
this by Nature I would guess yes let's
say that let's say a policeman showed up
at it doesn't matter what race you are
that show up at somebody's house and the
woman's Crying by Nature the policeman
would be like what did I do wrong yeah
just by nature would and that's okay and
they actually not I have nothing wrong
with that but it's like a lot of times
it's crying wolf
seen a chick where it's like she's
she's been you're like
you're like no what you're doing
[Laughter]
think about it men are so benevolent
that when they got power they gave it to
us they gave us inarguably more power
than men there's no saying that when the
man actually gains success
um by Nature he wants to take care of a
woman yeah when a woman gets success she
believes she doesn't need a man yeah and
it's like going and I'm like going and
no joke I've been very proud of this I'm
I'm I've always said I'm a provider and
protector and you know the most
disgusting words that came from to me
were from women
just because I want to protect and
provide or give somebody some of this it
was the women that were most critical it
wasn't the bad matter like how do I do
it how do I become a provider protector
like that and it was women in power that
I had my that's why I hired a bunch of
them that's why I got rid of the church
too because they're actually propagating
this to women and I watch them do I
watch them do it's so bad it's so bad
like have you seen those Sim pastors
that are like well she can't submit to
you unless you submit to God yeah and
I'm like well what about loving her can
you only love her when she's being
perfect and then you're putting the
responsibility on the women to decide
when he's following God like most guys
aren't going to go tell you to oh I've
heard this from Christian women
even locally here talk about this way
yeah I'm not going to submit to him if
uh no I believe he's not submitted you
don't get the choice while he's submit
it you know and I laugh about that I'm
like going and and I watch them and they
talk like you're gonna be doing this or
this like going girl
deal be quiet do you saying bite your
tongue on this stuff because you're
going to lose that guy and stuff like
that because that that constant
badgering especially if he's especially
if it's a if the man working on himself
that's the thing about it's like that
way and that's why you kind of got going
and then then they put the aspect of
guilt on them and and so watching so
let's go back to this then if you look
at you know the things of masculinity
okay and I've been I've I've built a
company based on masculine traits now
not fully because I believe that
masculine feminine have have its roles
okay so so give me your your concept on
this of toxic masculinity
oh well they tell they call everything
toxic when they say toxic masculinity
they're trying to get men to be women
thank you that's what I read yeah
because it's like they'll be like oh he
doesn't like talk to me and I'm like
well men don't want to talk like not to
you anyway they just want you to shut up
and like look pretty you know like
like
I was thinking okay we have this concept
that we came up with imagine okay the
world where women only got like a talk
meter and imagine like we could like
okay you say you you sleep with your
husband in the morning you get an hour
of talking you cook him three meals a
day you get another hour of talking
I was like there would be World Peace if
you nag it like goes down
yes I was like you know but I think this
was like women just tend to be more
chaotic and I think if you know that you
understand that you need men to help
give you order like I think I'm really
lucky where I have a really good father
that always gave me order and I think of
every time I didn't listen to my dad he
was always right I was like dang it like
I always thought I knew better and every
time I thought I knew better my dad knew
better yep and it's like but if you
don't know that then you as a woman like
think you know better and that's why I
think like the propaganda is mean to
women because it doesn't it's not honest
with us about how we are and if you know
how you are you can like put yourself in
the best position yep so I don't believe
in toxic masculinity I think why don't
we talk about toxic feminine in a deal
he's like well I think and I think that
I think masculine traits once again
um true provider protector uh
competitive you know laser focus all the
aggression all the things that that
build Society you know protect women and
other people from bad things happen in
the world you know I think uh you know
it's like uh those traits are so needed
in The Sapphires they've you know women
try to step in those roles and it's just
destructive it's it I can always tell I
personally now will not do business with
a man to where his woman is dominant oh
yeah that one bit it's actually the
worst business deals you ever do in
history because what happens is they're
not willing to do what takes and do
things right they're they're too
convinced it's like this it's like I
don't trust a man that goes to women for
advice because you know why because it's
really funny is it's very nothing but
this way by Nature I think that uh that
feminine traits there are certain
feminine traits not feminine feminist
feminine traits that you know you know
compassion nurturing caring they're
great but if a guy goes for that for
advice
compared to go to a guy for advice it
get you get two different worlds I have
a Christian chicks like freak out
because I put a tweet I said let me ask
my wife with like a barfing Emoji oh no
I wasn't talking about like you can't
talk to your wife but it's like guys
that go to their wife for advice yeah or
like the direction of like you can't do
anything without asking your wife for
permission I'm like like that's like so
demasculating over a guy and the
Christian women were like well a man
should get wisdom from his wife and I'm
like
yeah see that's propagated big time in
Detroit especially in your life is this
so in my because you think this way this
way you know Catholics have a lot of
stuff that I you know what's kind of
interesting about them and and that but
you also is this they also say that
women shouldn't be priests vice versa
things of that and they and you're right
and there was a central order that
everybody came back to for some yeah for
some things that way but then it was
like it was almost like
non-denominational churches became the
Walk of today yeah they've moved away
from the very strong stricts of this and
now it's like everything's Progressive
and that's why they say well no we we
are just you know as an obdious we just
don't follow these certain rules because
sometimes like wokeness a little bit to
there no it is it is and they they
realized this in the early like 1900s
they infiltrated all the churches
non-denominational just got it the worst
because there's no Central Authority
structure well and and now you have
churches that have pride flags and all
the stuff of this and it's like and
that's why and I'm going to bring this
up and it's why I've said this as a man
I don't ever want to sit foot in church
why would I listen to a guy that would
never even take advice from concerning
his life itself you're saying men are
very good at looking at our men and
going oh he's got something I
your friends here in town and I said
this to him I said let me preach on a
Sunday because the first thing I would
say is this how many you guys are
freaking broke here and raise your hand
get out of here what are you doing
sitting here for an hour you're not
honored God by being poor and by
actually your wife suffering and she's
stressed out because of money because
you're not a good providing protector
get your butt out of here well and they
always they always
um they demonize okay you hear so many
um
sermons on male sit but you never hear
sermons convicting female sin I'll give
you an example you know you'll hear
pastors say don't like cheat on your
wife that's wrong don't like sleep and
like use these like I hate the language
that they use like where the women are
just being used by the men when they do
promiscuity or whatever but it's like
I've never heard a sermon you are not
being faithful to the Lord if you don't
sleep with your husband because that's
what the Bible says you need to obey his
authority like I've never heard sermons
talking about women obeying men they
always put they always put the spin on
it because that's where passes yeah
they're supposed to obey the husband but
only if the husband's doing the right
thing it's like wait wait wait correct
you don't get a choice to submit or not
women don't have that conversation it's
like no no no no because what happens
they always think that they should have
the final say well and that's it's sad
because there's a lot of guys like
yourself and I think of my dad too like
my dad's not crazy religious and I'm
like I think there's so many men that
would be religious if if there was
actually a church that was like that
catered to the men
correct daily but the but they're all
like catering to the women because women
spend we make 80 percent of consumer
buying decisions we're the biggest
customers in church well and I'm open
about my life about a year ago I told
the pastor to piss off I told all these
guys that they're ridiculous and I
stopped giving in in the weeks before
that they called me up and asked me for
fifty thousand dollars and then his wife
comes along tells it to get in a vintage
car collection do you say it's like
going and that's you know I it's a it's
a crazy sad about that but it's like
they're the pastors aren't masking
anymore no they're not they're actually
nothing more than feminist and of today
yeah and stuff and it's it's uh it's
really sad in that way and stuff so
yeah so let's go in this now though so
because you said this multiple times are
men and women equal
I think men are superior being
crazy but I I literally the last three
months have been trying to think of one
thing women are better at and when I
found out the stat that women are more
likely to kill infants in the elderly
I'm like well we can't be more nurturing
I think we're better at like detecting
emotion but I'm like I'm sorry Men read
a room way better than women like you
can show me some study that shows that
and maybe there's some truth to it but
I'm like well Men actually do something
with it you'll see the women like going
crazy at the bar twerking on the tit you
know what I mean yeah and I'm like not
reading the room and I just couldn't
think of anything and when I came to the
conclusion was is men are superior
beings they can run Society they can
organize societies I think they're
smarter I think they're more clever
um it's not to say that women aren't
clever but it's just to say exceptions
not the rules yeah it's like I was even
thinking of myself and I'm like am I as
smart as Ben Shapiro I'm like no like
and I was thinking I'm like it's really
like most jobs that women excel in
monetize Beauty in some way and most of
the industries we take over we ruin I
was thinking about even health care it's
like that's like so many it's like 70
nurses or women and I always hear
always hear playing about the nurses
same with the teachers I always hear
people complaining about teachers when
women dominate an industry we just ruin
it now I'm not saying are there some
Industries we probably don't ruin
I don't believe it well I don't think
Chris because you know why but let me
let me explain something yeah I can I
can remember and I in my audience knows
this time very open about my life and
things of that is this is when women
enter Society what they do is they take
feminine characteristics that are really
just good for a home
oh that makes sense and what they do is
just now watch this and I personally
experience because I just fire a ton of
women not a joke and I actually it
brought in more men and the company has
gotten 10 times better and doubled and
stuff and doesn't take away from the the
creativity and things that women have
that are good that make it good even in
healthcare yeah it's just that but the
but the but I had to get them to
understand that you have to take on
certain masks and traits to even be good
at your job and stuff of that and then
you can intermix some of the feminine
things but if you if you think about
this way is is
um
some of them so let's just take one very
good feminine trait compassion okay but
if the it's infiltrated Sports it's
infiltrated the workplace because you're
laughing this competition which is a is
a very masculine trait it leads to
better performance uh better quality of
things everything that comes out of any
good product is based on competition
because another guy will compete with
another guy to actually win okay even
even an industry Health Care everything
that way now if compassion comes in and
competitus was down now they want some
equal outcome so you say listen it's
like you know everybody should get a
participation trophy every city a chance
to play there's not everybody should get
a chance to play well not even even men
to men aren't equal do you saying
because there's different
characteristics so think this way so I I
and this is where once again in a in a
in let's say a business setting if you
lose that Competitive Edge to make
everything better because you say well
you know you need to give this person a
chance because
um well they have less or this this it
makes a company worse yeah and women
that's why that's why we have once again
that's why we have sitting there going
you know even when he talks about
affirmative action trying to make
everything better no if you're just good
a men will seek out you ever notice this
I'm wealthy yeah and I'll get together
with rich white guys black guys Asian
guys do you know the one thing we do not
talk about ever what race
oh yeah no no one cares if money is
green no that's it money's green no one
cares but we don't it doesn't even cross
our mind because what we what we as men
draw together we actually make ourselves
better more competitive because we want
to help do you do you understand yeah
and so the competition is is is asexual
the company and so women that do is they
come into a competitive market but it's
really funny sports is the only place
that men are allowed to be men because
testosterone driven attack that person
beat them but the minute that you try to
bring it up to the workplace it's why we
you know you said this really good there
doing a show and I laughed my butt off
and I went to my HR department said is
this you think this is true and it's
kind of funny she's like yeah you said
that if women weren't in the workplace
HR wouldn't even exist yeah
said well and women are well I guess
today's women aren't obedient but we I
think
um maybe that's not I was thinking women
like it's it's not to say women cannot
do good things in the workplace but I
just think it's like
you always need a masculine like leader
and and you see all these diversity CEOs
that just run these companies into the
ground trust me I had to fire one
because it hurt our company I almost
said I almost had 12 people just walk
out because a horrible leader yeah and
now that it sounds funny and I've said
this my idea of my company's never
changed but I had to I had to rid the
majority of people I had read was
females yeah and because what happens it
does in Miami by females females that
were in a leadership position
a lot of people are going to hate that
because my dominant customer is a female
because you know why because I was a
great doctor females and I and I said
you know you know me as even as a doc
yeah I'm very I'm very empathetic to
yourself that we've been very hard on
you too yeah how many times I text you
at 10 o'clock at night bro I'll do sugar
today you're like yeah see look in the
face I'm like oh being hard on you do
you say it well but it's not kind to
women because then it's like you're
telling women to pursue these things
that we're bad at and then it's like
you're trying to be something you're not
like and I've had a little bit of
firsthand experience because what
happened was about six months ago I had
this idea of a network that it wasn't
just going to be me it was going to be a
network and like managing the people has
been the hardest part I hate it because
someone will piss you off and you can't
just separate it and like because my dad
my dad helps me and he's like all right
let's go through the numbers are they
doing a good job or it doesn't matter if
they pissed you off do you know what I
mean but it's so like I've sought out
like um male managers to come in and
like help me with this and I've just
been like 10 times happier since I got
guys managing the people and like
letting me just be creative and
yeah like I could even like I've done it
firsthand and I'm like we're not good at
it I can't imagine I did that for a
really short period of time and I hated
it and I don't think it's kind to women
to like tell women to do something we're
not naturally good at we're more
creative like we're more creative you
can I would say we're in an advantage
for Content creation like thank you you
can monetize Beauty like there are
things you can do that men cannot do and
that we have a natural Advantage at but
we pick like it's like you're you're
teaching the women to go at things we're
bad at and then we fail at them and then
get mad that we fail and then usually
Sue because that's what women do we just
whine and we'll sue you after
but it's actually and the one thing is
this that that's so the reason why and I
still employ more females than than men
I decide to put all those wonderful
women in those creative positions and
they Thrive yeah they Thrive and they're
happier yeah and then I got rid of the
female leadership and the women that
were on there thrived even more and
let's be honest like do we even like
working for female bosses we hate look
at all these videos a bunch of
everywhere I call them boss I
fired all the boss yeah like we
hate working for like it's so funny
because I had a whole show on this and I
asked women like do you prefer working
for women some people said they didn't
care but everyone that had an opinion
said Matt yeah and every girl that said
they had a boss and they hated it was
always a chick because Ann chicks are in
sexual competition with each other so
it's like if you get a really pretty
young girl like I think we've all In Our
Lifetime had an older woman that was
just a to us because she was
single and by her damn self yep and you
know you're young and pretty and you're
like why does this chick hate me because
you're telling the attention away well
it's funny now get this though so watch
this and here's one thing that I see now
and that's why
let me let me show you something
business I learned it took me 20 years
to learn this I always wondered why
um certain guys wouldn't step up to the
plate and then I found that the majority
of the circle that they hang out with
isn't men that's women it's women yeah
because by Nature watch this um I had a
family member that was in prison
and uh I used to go and visit them and
it was interesting because then during
they have a roll call and then I'd sit
and talk to the moms and there were
people that were there and it was funny
because compassion I think is a very
great trait I'm not compassionate I'm
male so we have daughters of course I
believe a strong man could go be tell us
somebody and then hold their daughter
later because to protect something that
way but then also you know you know I'm
using an exaggerated example but if
someone were trying to attack our
companies I'd have no problem you know
being physically violent if I need to
that way but I could also go home and
then play a game with my daughter yeah
Sam and I watch these women sitting in
prison and there's a you know my boy
he's a really good boy we're in prison
we're in prison see but they have they
have this over compassion aspect of it
that way and it's like and I'm sorry in
the competitive society that way you'll
say funny and watch this and talk about
religion see that's why Christianity has
lost its way yeah I'm the kind of person
that says listen I look at this
opportunity I look at this opportunity
that a young man to come to me and say
Doc why are you so successful I just
believe in Jesus this is me that's me
I'm gonna say watch Jesus is the reason
why I believe I'm so successful and I
can build upon that I said what doc you
tear in churches no don't confuse don't
conflate to two because if you look at
the most you look the most successful
they come at me for that yeah you're the
watch the most successful safe
prosperous City right now
is actually a very religious City Dubai
I was going to ask but the number one
thing that it respects there
and it elevates men yeah men and it
tracks the most beautiful women they're
not they're not fat
no joke that's why if you go to Dubai
it's like dude dude if you got your mind
muscle money go and you're saying go to
Dubai because you're gonna be respected
by other men you can walk down the
street without being mugged you go to
England you'd be stabbed for having a
good watch yeah you're saying you can't
walk New York City right now don't want
to go to San Francisco because there's
all over the the streets but the
idea is this it's like anytime that men
are elevated guess what happens society
and protection thing gets better when
men when everybody wins that's the point
when we win for ourselves that's right
yeah it's like that's why that's why I
genuinely believe like men have God
inside of them like I genuinely believe
like men naturally like have God because
there's a reason like why do men have
honor why do you met like I'm not saying
I know there's and I think usually when
the men don't have God inside them it's
because they have a woman's spirit
inside them well like the that's like
all the prisoners are from single moms
homes and I've always been very open
with my mistakes guess what happens the
worst times of my life is where women
are speaking of my year yeah
yeah worst time ever ever well it's like
instead of going because a man would
look at me said don't be such a
dumbass yeah well and and how are men
not supposed to act like women when they
go into a school system that's 85 women
that's constantly telling them to sit
still and that's teaching them like in
the I don't know what in the UK in the
80s they made
um everything more subjective so now I
can go to school and I can
um I can write a paper write an essay do
a project and that's more subjective
right where before it just used to be
standardized IQ tests where you would
take a test I would like that's what you
would study for and that's what you were
graded on but when it went to be more
sub because that's what women do we come
in and ruin industries make everything
subjective everyone's good at things and
and so we have the school system that
favors a feminine way of learning that's
teaching men to be women and then on top
of that they have single mother homes
that's why I said if there's not it's
not Daddy Issues it's mommy issues like
most of the people with daddy issues I
guarantee it's mommy issues 85 of the
time you and you watch if a dad was
really tough on a young man guess what
happens they turn out better yeah they
always did and it's like I used to sit
there and go my dad used to spank me
yeah it used to be like oh but then I'm
like going no that's why that's why
people and I think that psychology has
done a horrible job at this everybody's
blaming their childhood for something oh
it's a fake I've I've heard that's a
fake institution that it was like
created like psychology actually during
stand antidepressants there are zero
criteria forever given besides how you
feel and I've always said this I said
listen ladies the company say Doc I
think of you may have to press and I'm
like really why well because my hormones
are my most dollar place I said yeah
welcome to be a woman yeah
we know that's just even hormonal levels
change every single week and that means
physically mentally Ruby's different
every week and then you're trying to act
like you're stable trying to act like
you're you know and that's what I tell
people it's like going you know I always
say this you know we see all these women
in politics I'm like and they're cyclic
women and go where are they on their
period because I don't want them making
life-changed Seasons when they're in the
stress States I think women I always
said I wanted to run for an office just
so I could like repeal like take away
women's rights and then step down and
step down
and then doing way too much like to the
point we really you know what's funny
women haven't even thought about the
fact that women don't run Society like
it's so funny like women infrastructure
jobs so like when you build you're in
like the caveman days or whatever and
you wanted to build a society you're
like okay we need protection we need to
move the food around the Water Systems
all that stuff only seven percent of
women do those jobs and let's be honest
like two percent of those are police
officers are not really doing anything
no I don't want a female I do not want a
female police officer you know it's
really funny I've said this before ban
women from the police and the military
yes because you know what's so funny
I've said this before because you get
threats I get threats that's why I tell
people I'm like I said think this way
but if I had 30 women outside protesting
about what we do because there's a lot
of people that hate what we do I'd walk
outside get out of my place get
out of my way but I had 30 men out there
protesting it was a little bit more of a
worry
yeah even if they're small short and fat
they're still a bit more worried because
of what the damage and stuff they could
do well and what percent of
menstructor jobs
um a great majority of them are
infrastructure drops so it 45 percent of
men have an infrastructure job and that
takes into account like a percentage of
men are unemployed right but it's like
so why do women get the same rights when
we don't do the same amount of work or a
net loss on the taxpayer system and like
they'll always bring up the exceptions
it's like well don't you think like you
should vote like like you do well or
whatever but I'm like hell no like do
you know DARE stand today if women
didn't vote the Democrat Party wouldn't
even exist no because here's why because
Democrats sound more compassionate yeah
see if you think of it this way I've
always said this when it came to and
people know I'm I'm big in politics but
I hate all the parties but I said this
with my family I'm a communist with my
friends I'm a Democrat with with Society
with uh with my community I'm Republican
and with the world I'm libertarian now
the reason why is this is because I'm a
protector and provider so my community I
want to take care of them yeah but with
my with my friends a more democratic
let's do it together and if you need
help I'm here for I'll give you money
you understand it's really funny I've
always said this and everyone in this
room will say this right now do you
understand that if there was some
financial problem with these people here
they wouldn't go to their church first
who would they go to me me yet that
would that's what community was supposed
to be that's what church is supposed to
be that's when men really ran churches
and did stuff that way it was like it
was Community like because I will take
care of my community and everyone these
people I mean they understand that and I
and that but that's a masculine trait
well the churches will never win back
then until they give they have women
have to they have to get rid of these
single women's Ministries they have to
get rid of all the like marketing
they do towards like it's like they go
to church and it's like all this
feel-good stuff like here's our juice in
your crackers let's play this concert
and like I feel so close to God it's
like men aren't with this it's like
you're supposed to go to get a lesson on
scripture it's not supposed to be
entertaining you're kind of supposed to
be about here what you can do right here
you can watch you watch the service you
want on YouTube white people showing up
with a bunch of people you hate
well and until I think they need to do
an active marketing campaign to get men
back in church I really think they
should they need to put like money they
need to take away money from the women
and put it into the med and the only way
they're going to build communities is if
they start getting people married young
because if you don't promote if you
don't promote young marriage then you're
promoting promiscuity what percent of
people are going to be virgins by 25. my
daughter married 19 virgin stuff of that
yeah it's like because you know and and
the the men the men that want to date my
daughter had to come to me to ask for a
date first yeah and I looked and said if
you touch her I will kill you do you say
it well and this is a lot of men too I
think with good intentions kind of like
set women up for failure because you
know we've been proud propaganda for a
hundred years so this isn't just our
generation it's no it's like three gen
three four generations right where it's
like if you're not telling your daughter
to get married young like and I'm
talking like 18 19 20 22 tops right
you're promoting promiscuity because
most like your hormones are raging
you're young you're not gonna wait till
you're like most people aren't going to
wait till 25 26 27 it's certainly not
31. so it's like unless churches promote
young marriage and they're not setting
people up either and they get so in the
middle of it where they're telling the
women what to do instead of the men
telling the women what to do that it's
very like it's very it's very weird
Church dating I've well on top of it
it's really funny you ever you know I've
never had to do this uh on some of that
but you ever go to the um you ever sees
Church
um single things they're all women yep
but they're just all ugly people
churches don't attract that's why if you
look at the Muslim movies right now I've
I called this long time ago I said
ladies I said Muslim religion is going
to grow like crazy because it respects
men they hold them to high standard and
even if you don't have their beliefs
they do those two things and it also
attracts women
attracts good looking women because mind
muscle money tracks good-looking women
that's what I tell guys you don't have
to be good looking to attract a really
good woman you just have to get your
mind muscle money together and those
masculine traits will draw you to them
that way and that's why it's like then
then then on top it then you have these
uh and I wanna I wanna come back to the
point this do you know do you know so
funny I started to really look at this
over the last couple years
do you know the women that I caution men
to be very careful about is women that
lead Bible studies
because they're most combative with
their husbands and the way they speak to
them and stuff like that because they
think they're the authority yeah and I'm
like going and I'm like going oh my
goodness be very careful if a woman
leads a Bible study because then she'll
try to portray that thing to her man and
ask him to leave a certain way it's like
going quiet you don't even know what
you're talking about see people realize
this and I think this is where I do have
a little little empathy not not
compassion and sympathy because I'm not
a woman empathy being a man is more
difficult it really is is because it's
like you bet in top of it so therefore
we need to teach our young men to
actually really step up to the plate and
the world is actually yours it really is
well and
men that were the same and have the same
mental capacity as well as women of the
same like and I'm not even not anything
this to be mean I think it's kinder to
accept this yes like if
like if it like manage like this company
you know and I really thought I could do
it myself but then I just realized I'm
like you know I don't think I have it in
me let's find a man to do the job well
I'm a happier person let me show you
something so I once again let's go back
this I employ a ton of women and I can
honestly tell you one of my best
um practitioners it's actually a female
because she's very compassionate she's
very empathetic things of that but what
happened is this she tried to keep up
with me physically
as far as the model always worked
pushing stuff of that you know what
happened to her
she came back she passed out yeah she
physically I've always said this and I
even told her I said don't envy of the
man that's protective I'm like don't try
to push like me because your body can't
handle it and that's one thing where
being a protector and provider and see
all these all these good women sitting
here what happens this they understand
I'm saying you can't push like us it
will physically make you sick and I said
and I say like oh you hate women no I
don't I'm a protector and trying to
provide for you yeah but that's kind
like it's very kind honesty is like
there's a difference between women are
nice but a lot of times we're not kind
right and I think there's a kind like
yeah kindness and honesty because when
you lie to us it's like then we live our
lives based on this like delusion I like
that yeah yeah because here's what
happens women always say they want truth
that's not really true you do not want
the truth everybody but even men today
they don't want the truth you know why
because everybody loves this the truth
hurts they like that statement until you
have to tell them truth yeah and it's
like going no and it's like that's why I
hear pastors say about you know your
wife's your best friend and your partner
I'm like are you kidding me it's
feminist language you know also I say
like women that use the words narcissist
women that use the words coercion
women's that like even with the Tate
case like stay away from the chicks that
are saying oh they like the women were
manipulated because like they just see
the women of these these Eternal victims
I am so sorry if I with the case if I
had a boyfriend that convinced me to do
cam work and I went to my dad and I said
Dad I'm just the sad victim my dad and I
was like yeah but I lived in a castle in
romate like my dad would think I was the
dumbest chick ever he would not feel bad
for me well and it's like but all these
you see like I can see the mindset of a
chick based on how she reacts to these
cases like because like should they
women see other women the way they see
themselves so if they constantly see
themselves as victims they'll see other
women as victims and women are being
realized women have the most powerful
thing on the planet their sexuality yeah
it's powerful it's pure power it really
is and it's like and see that's why I
was like going you have a manipulated
you're using that process to get what
you want can we talk about how women
dress like hookers to work and get mad
at the men for trying it's like what did
you think
would happen Rebecca like you're half
naked at work you didn't think you
didn't think he was gonna try and you
also know usually funny people realize
this is if you truly have an HR
department and you really care about you
know things not being sexualized at work
you shouldn't let a woman wear red
lipstick but you know why
people will not realize this do you know
where a red list came from is it looks
like blush during sex yes it's a sexual
trait a Woman by natural physiology
blood will come to their lips and so
therefore guess what happens it turns
red it's what turns on the guy and see
it's it's basic biology and stuff like
that so it's like it's like so if you
really want to get into the aspect of
like oh you know men the way I could
work is like well then stop doing all
those things well
it has they'll start it they'll like be
like oh I want to get attention from
this guy but I don't want to date him so
like I don't want to do anything I just
want to know I want to get this
attention and then he gives them the
attention that they're kind of looking
for and then they'll be like oh he's a
creep it's like well Diane you're in
like these skin tight yoga pants yes and
you're like you're wearing nothing and
it's like I don't really care if you
want to do that but please don't want
I'm just tired of whining yes like
please just and it's like if I was a guy
I just wouldn't hire women because I
don't need a lawsuit later because all
the women do is just Sue they're like oh
I got wrong fully fired no you sucked at
your job yes oh I was harassed it's like
nobody was harassing you you're just a
like actually it's funny you say
that because I um one of my employees
that actually had to control some of the
docs that way
um he she would decide to take off and
not do a job that way and all of a
sudden he yelled at her and said what
are you doing could you put up back in
the office you're lying but he's like
you harass me
once again and that's actually going to
happen you know several times I watched
it happen to you know some acquaintance
of mine that's not part of my company
that way but it's like going and and so
the solutions once again so so let's go
back to this so what do you see as the
solutions then what do you see is Ed
what do you see as what's going to help
Society start to recover I only have one
solution we need to take away women's
right to vote I really
this is the people think I'm crazy for
this but I'm like look look I don't care
if we do it through make do only the net
taxpayers paying I don't care if we do
it only through military members paying
or like voting I don't really care if we
do it only by landowners that was how
the US started you didn't get the vote
for men and women because they didn't
think you're responsible enough if you
didn't own land to even make decisions
all I know is if we start putting some
responsibility tied to voting
I think we would see changes in policies
because the problem now like I don't
think anything will change until the
policies change I think there will be
like sub movements you know like like
yours and like small movements where you
know that maybe semi-fixed things in
like smaller communities but by and
large do I see there being less only
fans models in 10 years sorry I just
don't I see there being more can I can I
put some out there though yeah okay so
you're a digital content creator yeah if
I get another you see all my team starts
laughing if I get another woman that
because I like my Instagram so I do is I
I actually see who follows me yeah but
all of a sudden they click on it and
some hot chick and all sudden she says
uh digital Creator was it else Miranda
content creator and then I'm like okay
what content only fans you're not a
content creator your ass is not content
do you saying yeah I don't care if you
worked at the gym and got you know it
irritates me too I've had some on my
show and they'll be like bragging about
their production and like I don't look
at the actual stuff they make but I'll
see like promos on their page and I'm
like this is the worst camera quality
it's like if you're gonna do only fans
yeah if you at least do it well at least
these guys can do it better and saying
these guys who make it look good they
make me look good on camera so hey but
it's like um but no I really think like
until men take back power I really don't
think they can see a change because
because all of the systems are built for
women the politicians cannot win
elections men tend to vote for their
party they're loyal they're loyal to
their party as women we just you know
the king comes in we're leaving our
peasant husband sorry guys and and the
problem is we've built these
institutions that allow women to be
terrible but we're like these kids that
have just been given all this candy and
whatever we want for a long time and now
we're terrible just like a kid so you
say that yeah because you know what app
is this I mean this in a very great way
and we're getting noise over quite well
over over the last you know let's say
six months or so I told you I said I had
a little Purge I had to purge those
women out of the company everything like
that I believe it or not the company got
10 size better bigger oh I can believe
it either and and see and because you
know why because what happens is this I
brought back those masculine traits that
said you give everybody something even
better
and you're competitive not everybody
gets a chance and what happens this and
I got rid of all the Christian
out of my life now remember not Jesus
let me make that very clear although
over spiritualized Christian
that way which is all feminist crap and
I start to actually say okay listen and
guess what happens I started to track
more strong males
and company got better I even started to
attract great females I'm sorry one of
my one of my great females in my life is
right there Aaron Walton it's kind of
funny and she even thanked me because
I'm making her husband a ton and he's a
great guy make a ton more masculine it
made their life better overall do you
Zan you guys want to work for women
no they don't
but see but on the flip side but you
also have to they all they also have to
work for a strong man yeah a lot of men
today are propagating to feminism
thinking they're doing the world well
yeah yeah it's it's all a lie and I
really and it's really sad because I
think it like it
it leaves damn near anything like like
think about it think about this
transgender stuff is that men pushing it
now it's women it's women pushing that
yeah
off of horoscope signs
that's what like how uh this is
everything
that's huge right now especially in
California it's based on that are you
Pisces you are making the most important
who to reproduce with yep off of a
horoscope sign we also pick criminals
we're more likely to reproduce with
literal criminals like this is how silly
we are yes and when you realize this
you're like okay wait why are we letting
them make a lot of choice you know and
I'm not saying you should like like
women should have no rights like even in
the 1600s women could like could own
property there's always been high IQ
women in society that have done things
there's always been an exception to the
rule but I think we need to remember
what the rule is and the funny thing is
most of the women I know that make a lot
of money that do really big things if
you explain this to them they're like oh
yeah women are idiots do you know who I
love hiring more than anything right now
what women who are older they already
develop their family and now what
happens look at see they're shaking her
head right now because now because all
of her kids now are are uh older yeah
what happens is and now they've
fulfilled that generational thing to be
able to have those family to pass down
that stuff that way and now they say you
want something now maybe I'm gonna go
work for a strong man to lead and
actually and I can develop my career and
take the craft that God gave you do you
see I'm saying and things like that and
I'm seeing that that then women are
really happy with the career because you
know why because their family's already
developed you know it's funny it's funny
too when
when female kids like are so much more
like they understand that men and women
are different because when you raise
kids you can't you can't avoid it like
even even from like what they're super I
just um all my nannies came back this
weekend like so I grew up with like a
bunch of nannies and they all came back
and like brought their kids and even
just like playing with like the the girl
and the boy kids they're so different
from like the eight like really really
young just in the way they act and it's
like you know mothers especially that
have raised like good kids they're not
you tell them this stuff they're like
hell yeah the women love the draw it's
funny you say that because if I ask a a
young lady
um and they're scared to say us I said
no no let me see a question what if your
husband made enough money she could stay
home and raise your kids a certain age
they said I do an RP oh yeah I do
heartbeat but I can't say that because
then they're like oh my goodness you
know but then your your wasting all
those years you could be going to
college doing some of this I'm like
going well no no you're actually taken
away from some of those important years
that when you are 40 50 years old look
back and say my kids are good now I can
pursue something a little bit more yeah
you're saying and then and then it's
it's because I think that it's ruining
society that way and I think and here's
what and I think though and here's you
know I'm gonna say this I think it's
only men that can fix this yeah oh God
you want women to fix it we can't fix it
no no no and that's the thing and that's
what that's why it's like it's like it's
kind of funny and the reason why I bring
that up is going
um
you get a lot of hate I'm gonna get even
more hate because I'm a rich white guy
oh yeah if I if I was at least oh these
evil men that just built that's the
point of society yeah somebody decide
for everybody to to laugh in that way
and I said and I once again I'll make it
very clear on getting money from
government I started you saw my history
today I start with 500.
you say and you honestly funny the only
people ever pushed against me was
actually women the I'm not it's not a
joke yeah it's like anatopic Christian
women oh yeah a guy's gotta be don't say
I just you I just I just have
like a triggered like I just I think
it's so hard because I really do believe
in God but Christian women trigger me
them oh they treat me the most right now
driving annoying because because they're
tribal and they they fall into the
propaganda of modern day feminism in the
church that way yeah and sitting there
going and and that's the worst part
about it and I seen it and I watched it
and I'm like going I'm like no ask them
could your husband buy a house that you
didn't like and would you just support
him not give him hell move to a
different side of the country would you
just say okay whatever you say I trust
you it's never toys that's always well
but he needs to get wisdom from his wife
and it's like like because that's how I
realized you could like kind of see
where a girl's heads at is like asking
those questions like are you gonna
support him when he makes a decision
that you disagree like you think it's
the wrong decisions can you shut up yep
and the thing is as women like we've
never been told do that we've been told
their opinion matters right well on top
of it I've and I've and I got a lot of
young men that work for me I said listen
you know how you can start to look for a
wife
start making decision and see what a
response is hey I'm gonna because you
know they want a man that's cheaper okay
honey tonight we're gonna go to this
restaurant nowhere with this okay
red flag right there yeah hey one or
this no Liza listen you know if you want
me to be a man let me be a man because
because a true man knows this for
example is this watch this we got Justin
over here okay good strong young man
that way let me see a question Corinne
do you know what she likes
do you really have to ask her
see so if you plan to date you know what
she likes you know what she wants to do
see that's the point A real man would be
like no he will stalk and investigate
you yeah because he wants to win your
heart it's a competition because guess
what Justin you're not the first guy I
thought about dating Corinne see my
point let's see so therefore we want to
be competitive yeah so ladies shut up
it's a joke shut up we know what to do
stop especially when you're married or
you're dating a real man okay I'll tell
you another red flag that I realized
women that say like when they talk about
their exes and say I did so much for him
because that means that she keeps score
because come on what woman has done for
more more for a man that a man has done
for her
it's either you like bombs or or you're
keeping score constantly right and you
that's the worst thing you want is a
woman that's spiteful because marriage
like you're never gonna know like you're
supposed to be selfless and it's not
going to work if you're constantly
keeping track of everything you did for
him so honestly that's like well another
like go ahead but here's Amazon think
about this pastors like a Christian man
does this this and they give him a
checklist oh and never the women yeah
they have men checklist that way I'm
going
dude you know yeah am I going
on top of it it's all based on lies
anyways and stuff like that's like this
is what we see you know it's like here
I'm sick of the Christian broken chick
oh my God but I just I just screwed all
these men because I was so broken I just
like to live in reality look chick you
were horny you know this is the king you
said no to the peasant the king you know
tossed you aside that's kind of like it
just like take the L but I'm really
tired of these like stupid SOB stories
where now we're just gonna go to the
churches and like I just like to live in
reality and we take away from reality
when we're just like removing
accountability off the chicks by saying
I was just like broken like I mean it's
funny because you don't sleep funny you
ever notice it's a sidetube we we
Elevate the single mom
we elevated you know you know what I'm
saying they're the rude of all the
world's problems right it's like Elevate
them like they are so virtuous that they
do this I'm like
um no you're saying be in a relationship
with anybody men or women are tough
life's hard you know what I'm saying
that way but it's like so therefore
guess what happens like going why are
you elevated to like you've done
everything much better than a married
couple that raised kids and stuff that
just because you did it yourself well in
every problem is in society is literally
like all the prisoners come from single
moms all the people in men's mental
institutions come from single moms I
think that off the bat men should be
given custody yeah I I know this is a
controversial I literally think men
because men if it's a good mom will let
her watch the kids if he like knows okay
it didn't work out between us but women
it's like we're too spiteful we get too
angry we use the kids as Weapons other
women about it yeah and I'm just like no
give the kids to the men and they can
decide if the chick gets to see the kids
because most men again they have that
honor that dignity the respecting inside
of women especially during a breakup oh
my gosh like it yeah well you're gonna
say you're the best version of yourself
during a breakup did you ever notice
that that when there's a single mom she
has to be both dad and mom but when
there's a single dad he has not to be a
mom
you ever notice that well because the
traits of a guy
can can hold them even if it's a
daughter yeah to enter Society better
than if it's just a single mom oh the
single fathers turn around to single
father homes turn out way better than
single mother like it's not even close I
know I read the stats but you see but
see why because the masking traits make
you better for society and make you
better for a thing now I'm not saying
that once again that feminine qualities
can't have some things great at home
because I think that that can bring to a
man that I tell people think about what
I do for a living think what you do for
a living you're at War it's War you know
what I'm saying because you have people
that discreet your ideas things of that
and so the last thing that I want when I
go home is war yeah yeah
and I and and therefore if those
compassionate feminine qualities are
there it can bring peace to a great man
that's masculine and stuff and I think
that's why the dynamic Works quite well
together but the minute that uh and I
always said I said this way women by
Nature have a much higher time in
society because they have to enter a
masculine world and take house traits to
survive but then when they go home they
have to become more feminine because if
they keep those masking traits a guy's
like dude I didn't come here to be
combative with you I'll come back with a
guy it Society to dominate and compete
but not at home okay do you know what's
crazy it's like all of us women
got like this Youth and Beauty right we
start with and it's like we could have
married a millionaire and I was even
thinking I was like I was thinking about
myself and I'm like at 18. my strategy
could have been go marry the richest guy
possible for life and I was like but
instead I was like let's chase a
volleyball an industry where you make
zero dollar like you make and I was
thinking I'm like wow it's like men if
they had what we had like it's like they
would just pick a very different look
you know I mean I'm like wow we are not
logical y'all so funny but that's not
because you're right because they're
they're most attractive years the women
are tell them go and Chase a career and
also I'm sorry but you get past that you
get past well I I just okay I've watched
certain podcasts and I'm like I'm
watching some of the opinions on
relationship that way and I'm like and
I'm laughing because they're like you
know a woman past certain age I
personally think they said that that
they're gonna they have a certain
element to age that way but then what
happens this is there's certain
characteristics that make them
attractive Beyond Beauty that are there
but they really if they don't capture
things when they're youthful yeah what
they now do is is a lot of these guys
actually look at for certain qualities
older and then you've been through
you've lost some of the major traits
that we really you know look forward to
and then on the flip side you're gonna
see this I'm now watch I see this a lot
um and I feel and here's where I do
here's here's where it's a little
different for me on this
I think that uh that the young ladies
today let's say they are let's say they
want to be submitted they want to do
things that we're talking about that way
I still think they have a hard time
though I think that they're going to
marry older men let me explain why let
me explain why and the flip side a lot
of people like they call like you know
the tapes or freshmen they call them
like well you know because they only
want to date younger girls but think of
this way a girl when you when you have a
a young lady
um today what they'll do is they'll
they'll look at a guy and say He's got
potential
that potential doesn't always turn out I
would say ladies right young ladies
right now if you want to look for a good
man
look for the Dead
do you know why because that dad's going
to pass those masculine traits onto him
and there's potential but you could be
20 years old and your your girlfriend's
20 years old that girl is actually
marrying for potential and not really
results at least you might see women now
18 when they go I want that millionaire
I'm gonna marry him when he's 28 because
you know why because he's already worked
through all the potential and started to
to represent his masculine traits later
yeah well we want a guy that can give us
wisdom and it's like
no I agree with you I think Aldo's
better yeah yeah and I always tell women
it's really sad though so I tell women
it's like it's really funny it's like if
you look at a 30 year old woman that's
single right now what they do is they
say well I want a 35 year old girl while
he stands like good luck you're not
gonna happen because a 35 year old man
that's got together doesn't want a
35 year old you know what he wants 25 25
year old and a 45 year old wants a 35
year old yeah and see it so I said lady
and Lady Skin I say that even my girls
here they're single and they're actually
good submittal amazing women and like
and and I have one who is just she is
she is a great Christian girl submittal
she's kind of that kind of girl away and
she's 40. I said you gotta look for a 50
year old and she's like I don't want a
50 year old I'm like then you're gonna
stay single because you know why a 40
year old guy that's your age that you're
looking for yeah doesn't want a 40
. no I know it's hot and it's hard for
women to say that it's hard for them to
accept that that's so bad like manage
like wine so it's like why don't you
just like go older like I don't it's
really funny it is what you're saying
then it's a little derogatory if it's
kind of funny it's like men age like
wine lemonades like milk yeah yeah we do
unless you're into Welsh way because
they do keep their beauty and youth and
look good yeah so that's why people man
you have some good looking women around
here like yeah because they take care of
themselves healthy wise yeah oh my gosh
it's crazy if you look at pictures of
like a hundred years ago 50 like the
women just looked even without all the
Botox and like they looked younger
well that's why you sees pictures
circulating on Instagram things that
they show pictures of people
oh yeah and stuff like that and they're
just because once again it's just been a
healthcare has been dominated by all the
bad things you know it's like and that's
why I think I enjoy life so much because
my whole my yes my mom about this that's
my dad
I was always known as rebellious kid um
but this way this where I where I will
give God the credit in this way it's
like he was preparing me for this he's
preparing me to go there's a lot of
coming in the future and you're gonna be
one of the voices against it and I think
that's uh it's been a great thing to see
that happen and if not we're I said I
think it takes the men of today to step
up and say no I think I think it's a man
of today they actually step up and say
okay listen churches you suck
he's in and and let these young men know
that don't be duped by the church he
used to work at a church I stole him got
him away from it and so it just teaches
you to be a cent for a lifetime just
like make her happy explain this for my
audience what's a simp uh a simp is like
is like the worst life ever because
women are never going to be happy sadly
enough but women like it's like and Sims
are guys that like they cater to women
yeah and they cater to women that don't
deserve it like there's nothing wrong
with like I mean quote unquote simping
for a chick that deserves it but it's
like a chick that does nothing for you
doesn't listen to you is fat like it's
like what do you what are you putting
this chick on a pedestal for yeah and if
you have a if you have a great woman
spoil like crazy yeah I'm saying yeah
provide for them be a provider be a
protector let her you know it's like
because that should be and it's really
funny isn't it funny today that um that
women on the flip side let's say they
they are great women they they want to
submit they want to do those things and
then they're demonized if they look at a
preference of a man have money I might
go on
um I think that's why we work for it
well I'm gonna do a flip side a little
bit I mean the question is is does the
average chick submit to a guy that makes
forty five thousand dollars a year in a
five nine no and the problem is I
actually don't and I think we should
encourage that a bit more because most
chicks are average but the problem is
like women have been batting out we've
been batting out of our league for too
long like you know most girls that are
fours five sixes have been dating the
eights nines and tens yeah but what
would you consider dating because maybe
they're sleeping with them okay they
think they can marry them you know you
say I mean maybe they'll get the guy for
six months or maybe they'll maybe
they'll date him and like be boyfriend
and girlfriends for six months well he's
just not you know or you know they'll
sleep with it whatever it is right
they'll deal with but it's like you know
we're telling the chicks that this like
that you're so special when the truth is
you're not special you're probably
average looking and that's not an insult
most guys are at like and so like why if
you if you demand a guy that makes say
80 000 a year it's like well are you in
the top 20 of women because you're
asking for the top 20 of men and are you
an eight or higher and if the answer is
no it's like okay we'll make maybe you
should go a little lower because like I
like the 40 year old chick at 40 you
know you're you're below average right
sorry like if you're above average
someone would have got you by now so you
know there's some deficit in something
yep because and and I say this even like
even as myself like I say the best women
are scooped up before 25. that's sorry
like and you can't be traditional sorry
you can't be a traditional women if
you're single after 25 you up
somewhere right either you pick bad guys
either you put something else for
whatever it is or you're batting out of
your league and most chicks because of
social media we're batting out of our
league but nobody's told us that we've
just said we're so special we're so
smart and you're a queen and you deserve
the world and it's not your fault at all
that these guys treat you like well
it's like I'm like I'm sorry good women
don't get treated like and good
women like understand where they're at
like you know so you you know yeah and
that's people I don't I don't say this
to say I'm like better than someone I'm
just like looking at the market I've
interviewed like hundreds of women at
this point and they all date the same
guys and then wine and I just hate
whining yeah God I hate whining it's
funny because there's a lot of now what
do you say to the women that say there's
no good guys out there I'm like there's
guys everywhere well the problem is
they're probably are it's like they're
batting out of their league right and
like the women it's so funny we have
that that chick that just went viral
that said she wouldn't date a bus driver
and that's my question like when the
chicks say there's no good men like
would you submit authority to a bus
driver would you listen to a bus driver
now the other problem is we've been sent
men saying oh no you can't submit to a
bus driver when it's like okay they're
they have a job that's needed right and
it's actually not an easy job to drive a
bus right like I think that's hard you
probably can't do it so it's like like
I I think like when they say that it's
just you're shooting too high because if
you were that great someone would have
scooped you up at 18. yeah yeah you
would have been gone and I think like
it's okay to have a little humility and
say maybe there's places you need to
improve maybe you got to lose weight
maybe you gotta you know be healthier
maybe you got to figure out how to
listen to that like whatever it is but
you're never gonna even know there's a
problem if like you're so delusional to
think like there's no issues do you
think
and I'll give you an example you know I
realized I was like I was always a
tomboy like the biggest tomboy and I
because I did sports for 16 years and I
realized I was like wow there's a lot of
skills I don't have because I've been
playing I've been spent most of my life
in a gym and it's like you know you
can't have realizations if you're like
like you just think you're so amazing
all the time yeah so
when it comes to you know let's say
the females of today okay
um what advice would you give to them
let's say they were 30 years old let's
say they versus 18 year old to to
capture the guy that they want oh okay
okay if I was 18 again oh my gosh I have
the best strategy all right you need to
get a job okay one you need to get a job
somewhere where there's highness there's
rich men yes I'm like okay because I
thought about this I went to my dad
bought box seats okay and there was a
chick that was giving us the dessert at
the box seats and she was so fat and I
was just thinking that is the worst like
waste of an opportunity like she could
be hot and skinny Angels guys what and
she's gonna grab on those guys
she was a fatty I was like this is just
a waste this is just a waste and you're
giving them dessert the men love food
you don't have to make it but they'll
associate it with yes you know it's
really funny you know you know and I've
said this the guys are like you know doc
you know
um I'm young I want opportunity I said
then guess what go get a job at a
country club oh even guys because then
just and be respectful to the to the
rich guys and we take recognize of it
that way yeah and then I would say study
the guy you want like okay let's say
whatever your type is maybe your type is
you know a German guy yes or Nigerian
whatever it is study you got to study
with the foods those type of guys like
whatever maybe you like Farmers maybe
like what is the type of guy look like
you're looking for like can try to
figure that's what I would do that's
what I would tell I would say go to the
box yes although there might I was
thinking we have the same advice yeah
yeah well see my daughter my daughters
have an advantage do you know why
they're surrounded by doctors yeah and
my oldest daughter married one you
saying and he's 10 years older than her
yeah he's saying and he's an incredible
man you're saying but who's who do you
think is also leading them on a daily
basis
me and you think I'm joking my daughter
is a night my daughter who's actually
following my footsteps
um I had to I had to Lily even have
recent conversation with her it was a
fantastic conversation I said listen
there's things that as I pass this
company down to you that Devin will
handle that you will not
because number one he is meant to take
the stress
you're saying and it's really funny I've
been having this conversation with my
daughter right now about this a little
bit that way because um once again she's
20. she's probably got about about three
and a half four years left of college
I'm like don't lose the next four years
about building a family just because you
want to graduate college on time
I said because you're going to look back
and one day your mother is gonna pass
away and there's gonna be generations of
kids there and they're not going to look
at me and say oh look at look at Dr
Flynn did they're gonna look at Chrissy
and go that came from her
that came from her they'll be like but
did I provide to make it happen and see
we're looked at generationally different
and what happens this and I said faith I
said don't don't fall in that trap of
society you don't that's not represented
in Flynn culture the Flynn culture says
listen you know reproduce like crazy
yeah I always tell them I have 17 kids
you know saying and it's like because
that believe it or not you may be a
fantastic doc one day Faith and but
you're not going to be you're even as
great as you could you're going to be as
a doc and things that you're still not
going to be known just for the purposes
of History
your great grandkids are not going to be
thinking about what you did for a living
you say and it's like so what would you
then say now
to the 30 year old
that has that has been through some
things okay and stuff like that and
and uh
you know
listen to your material things at that
and saying okay
how do I get that I think you've got to
start with like you got to figure out
what's wrong with you and I think you
should talk to your dad or your brothers
first because those are really the only
men that are going to be honest with you
um and you got to fix it so maybe you're
fat
well you're right because baby you don't
want to ask another guy because he won't
sleep with you yeah exactly maybe like
because they'll say Oh no you're a great
girl there's like even like no offense
the 40 year old chick for some reason
she's single I don't know what it is but
nobody makes it to 40 if you're that
great without something wrong with you
so like your third maybe you're
argumentative you know uh maybe like
whatever whatever it is you gotta figure
out what it is fix it and then figure
out where are the men that you want and
you qualify for and that's really really
and my honest opinion you're only I
wouldn't even get that answer from me
I'd get that answer from men I'd ask the
men that are going to be honest with you
what type of men that you qualify for
and where can you find them it's funny
let's bring up that girl and I'll keep
her name private obviously but but she's
over spiritualized and the church has
infiltrated her brain like this is the
guy you deserve I'm like that's not true
you see that's the thing the church puts
this crap in your head about I might go
on girl you're 40. real life is you're
not as attractive to a 40 year old
anymore especially because she wants the
standard of guy and people say well I
have standards I'm like then sorry
ladies you don't have and Society this
is where they have a hard time saying
you men are the gateways to marriage
women are gateways of sex yeah so that's
why women like well you know I'm
sleeping with them like so he's not
marrying yeah do you saying because
you're not you're just the gateway to
sex you're not the Gateway the marriage
we decide who we marry yeah and stuff
and and the thing is like going so then
I tell you it's and and so her bad
quality is she's been listening to
church people for a long period of time
and so therefore she has these did she
do the Born Again thing no men hate that
no no what happened is this she said she
just uh um what they do is they
a lot of these Christian women it's so
easy to to manipulate Christian women so
easy too you know Sam because all you
have to do is say God every third word
oh yeah and you can be a criminal and
guess what happens he's I watch women
these guys will get out of jail and you
become saved and he's like he's such a
good question he just got out of prison
he needs some time to work his out
do you understand it's like you can fake
Christian people they're so tribal that
all you have to do is do all the kitchen
Christian catchphrases and these
Christian women fall for all that
and see so what happens so she
does the same thing the idea is this
it's like so then you have and and it's
really funny you said something that was
quite quiet thing it's actually not that
hard to please a man you just gotta
figure out how to please him
Nissan and it's like that that's a
that's a very and you can study guys
yeah you can't they're very do you have
something to do ask a guy they'll tell
you what they want
look at this
it's like ask them do you say like
when's the last time you asked your
husband how you can make his life easier
yeah yes because a real husband a good
husband is gonna be out there in the
battle like you said it's not easy to
drive a truck it's not easy to those
things and so the last thing they want
is another battle do you saying and so
it's like and it's like uh um
guys don't get married to actually have
a battle at home and they just don't
you're saying it's like uh I think
that's so it's good I think that the the
feminists have perpetuated that to it's
like and then and then they tell them um
can't even it's tough okay because from
a Christian like I mean a group cat I'm
Catholic so it's like from a Catholic
point of view I understand what they're
saying like they find God and now
they're like oh I need to like wait till
marriage but it's like you're gonna have
a tough time selling that if you're like
a used Honda Civic with 100 000 miles
you know what I mean like it's like good
luck you want to like and you're not
even gonna respect a guy that wants to
do that because like you kind of know
it's like yeah you let the last 33 guys
hit for free but now exactly now you
have standards you know it's kind of
like you know
actually I know I know someone like this
and it's really sad she oh my gosh she
found this guy who was he he was really
good looking he was tall she really
liked him but he wasn't like Christian
enough so she dumped him and I'm like
you know with women it's so rare we find
a guy that like we actually like and
it's so rare that like you know on top
of that she found a guy that likes her
to like it's all good but she's like
he's she's like yeah um I just he's not
my pastor told me he's not Christian
enough I'm like
she's like 29 I'm like girl what are you
this might be okay you know well because
they perpetuate Church stuff they don't
follow these things that they're going
to be a horrible man
they do and it's like they don't follow
these tribal things that we have set
down and that's why that's why no words
can agree on anything then what happens
this then they create these unrealistic
standards that a guy isn't even going to
be he's saying I'm like I'm like listen
I'm like ladies you know if you
understand you're not supposed to
understand who we are what we want to do
you just got to get out of our way just
get out of weight because you're getting
our way see that's what I tell people
and this is by competitive nature or
anything I've always said this and I
said to me in business it's asexual if a
woman's trying to be with me I'll do
everything to destroy you
yeah do you have a point yeah I know
it's like that's like I said this and
this is gonna probably lose some of my
female Audience by me saying this I
cannot wait for the day the 300 pound
linebacker hits a female that's a
running back or a punter and actually
levels them out and culture is going to
go crazy because they're gonna be like
that that one kicker for the college
team she punted and she ran off the side
of field because if one guy would have
hit her instead of that it's like what
do you write hey you want to be treated
as equal then take your hits but see
women don't want to do that in business
they think that we're equal that way
like no listen I will I'll work you I'll
compete you and I don't care that you're
a woman oh yeah we can't win no oh my
gosh and I was thinking like what I was
trying to think of something women were
better at I was like cooking we're
totally better cooks and then I looked
up the best chefs in the world yeah the
top National and chefs I'm like you put
a dollar at the end of anything metal
just learn how to do it better better
that's what we're competitive yeah we're
competitive that's the thing even though
I
know I vanished just like being that
like Beauty even older women like men
are a little bit nicer to you like the
world's just a little Kinder we have an
advantage yeah we still lose but you're
saying there's three things I think that
the for example that makes a woman's
Beauty continue for their whole life
regardless their age and supportive
because you want something when you're
supportive to your man what happens to
this you're the most beautiful woman in
the world because you know why because
he what we have to go through mentally
and physically a day just to provide is
huge that's why I said sexy Serenity and
uh and um supportive and see I use the
word supportive and says submittal
because the majority of famous freak out
until you talk behind closed doors with
them and they go I said listen if you
knew a guy could take care of a and
do stuff what would you do he goes she
goes I go along for the ride but I can't
say that in public I'm like why not
you're saying it's it do you understand
that those basic principles that make
life better for everybody are looked at
as demonized right now it's like it's
really it's really flipped bad has
become good and good has become bad it's
it's like and we reward checks for it oh
it's ridiculous you can make 50k a month
on only even though most girls
it's so it's 197 I looked it up I know
that's the average that people makes you
know what you know what's funny too it's
like the only time women are good at
only fans like even men figured out how
to have us make money on only failure
like guys like the tapes or like guys
similar to them I'm like we can't even
do sex work better than that well I can
make it great I bet you I have a
marketing company I can make a great
only fans girl great camera angles
things like this it'd be fantastic I bet
you the metal figure out how to make
money off of the AI stuff if you ever
think this way do you really think a
woman knows what a guy wants to look at
no so you actually say girls here's what
you do with your boobs here's how you
bend over here's how you do things that
way because a woman isn't going to tell
her what to do they'll think well oh
this is more we don't care about oh my
gosh the biggest like red pill I had was
when girls would come on the show and
the girls that like my producers picked
out is like the most attractive were so
different than who I would have and it's
so funny because I realized I'm like do
men even like look at your face I'm like
it's like all body they like glance at
your face
hey my eyes are up here don't give a
about your eyes
don't give a crap about them
[Laughter]
what's right
that that's the do you know the first
thing I say is sexy you saying because
we do not find obesity sexy we don't I'm
sorry you're saying and it's in and they
call fashioning no we don't we don't and
they try to force women are trying to
force not man sorry you don't want a fat
ass girl you don't want a fast girl see
no whales for you guys no none oh that's
so great no it's Joshua nope see the
thing that's fine it's like get this so
we did this we did this we did this with
uh with my two podcast host Dana and and
Ross and everyone's walking by because
she said this she goes not every guy
wants a Victoria Secret model I said
Whoa stop saying that because yes we do
yes we do well not the ones nowadays
there no they're fast no but I say we do
we want we want it because you know why
it's like and see it's in men are
demonized for their preferences but
women are encouraged to actually have
their preferences that way but guess
what happens this it's really funny it's
like Hey listen in
you know so funny guys can survive alone
I'm a Loner by Nature yeah like I said I
I people I love being around my people
but I don't need to be around people
yeah I like more time alone than I like
with our people women are not that way
they're not meant to be that way and so
it's like so they need our people so
that's why we're like well you'd be
alone it's like going I don't mind being
alone I could sit in my office and work
on things and be it's just the nature of
it that way and so that's why it's like
okay listen to all things happening I'm
like going listen you know it's more
it's better to find out what the man
sees are than the woman because by
Nature ladies and people don't realize
this by Nature if he involves you in his
life he wants to provide and protect
he does you just have to shut up in
God's way and let him do it his way and
stuff with that and and if he asks you
for a question ask you for something
that way then he's looking for once
again just to hear what you have to say
but he doesn't ask don't give me your
opinion because he really doesn't care
I have some people don't give me pins
because I don't care don't give a
well I mean here watch this you know
this as well you are an owner of company
do you think that the person that sweeps
your floors actually understands what
you go through
no so then how why would you care about
their opinion
see that's what I mean sincerely I don't
give a crap what a person says of how I
should run the company you actually make
fifty thousand a year I guess that's the
funniest thing when people will like
message me like telling me how I should
have debated like everything I'm like go
do it then do it that's right I'm like
go do it
I'm like if people or they'll be like oh
she shouldn't be in the position she's
in I'm like well no one cares what you
have to say Lauren like yes it's like
well think about this in athletics is I
love this I love how people criticize
like let's say Aaron Rodgers because you
used to play here now he's in New York
and everything they criticize their
Rogers I'm like why would you criticize
them you can't do what he can do you're
not been in a position you've never had
a 300 pound linebacker running at you do
you saying so it's like I I don't I just
look at the talent and go hey he's good
at what he does yeah and it's like and
if he makes a mistake I'm like I
wouldn't even know this mistake because
I don't even know what to do you say it
yeah it's like but see that's what
that's that's what happens but when we
when we give people insight to like you
think you can know what I go through
that way and it's like you've just
you've just taken away that experience
or that wisdom that you should say hey
what's it like owning a company like
that what's it like with these things
happening you know Sam and I think
that's I think that why why feminism has
actually been so bad especially for men
is women are portraying what it's like
to be a man yeah
man and we're not met nope and so it's
like we'll spend our whole lives trying
to be a man we're not a man we're never
going to be a man instead of you know
using the things
that women are better at or women have
an advantage in and making money that
way it's like what why do you need like
okay there's always been exceptions but
the rule is you're probably not going to
be a good CEO probably not going to be a
good CFO like you'll probably do better
working for a guy and that's okay yep
yep yes and that's why listen ladies you
do better with a man than you do without
them do you saying that's why I said
single motherhood it's like I'm sorry I
don't celebrate it I don't care that you
know that she did it on her own actually
if you ever ask the women that if they
did on their own they didn't want to do
it at all yeah just like you ask a woman
they listen if you had the opportunity
as a young lady to stay home and and be
taken care of by a man buying closed
doors they always say heck yeah and
especially then there's a there's a
point in their life to where they maybe
have a career but then they start to get
older in what they want to do they want
to go back to that being taken care of
again yeah and stuff and I've seen that
too and it's it's great because they're
like going I'm not meant to continue
Bush I'm probably gonna push till the
day I die yeah it's just that trait of
competition what I want to accomplish
and the Legacy that I want to create I
want to create the flood Legacy that's
going to continue to pass down that way
and so I have that drive well that's the
other thing even if you out earn a man
in your 20s he's going to outwork you in
the long run like his women that's a
they're using this all these stamps I'm
so tired of the Sims they'll use the
stat and be like oh well women under 30
are out earning men I'm like yeah
because we're hot or under 30. yep so
we'll get like a higher paying sales job
or higher paying debt pharmaceutical
drug reps yeah whatever it is so sure
like we make more monies in our money in
our 20s and our 30s but we always we
always get tired and the men can do it
till they're 60 or 70 but it's like
you're you're going to want to retire in
your 50s as a woman or 60s look at this
so I have an acquaintance who used to be
a pharmacist who drove up good looking
as can be that way she was highly
recruited as in her 20s early 20s
not because of her skills because of her
looks yeah this is not this is not like
a secret then they send the best looking
girls not guys the only time they hire
guys is if they're African-American or
things like that trust me I have an
African friend who's actually a sales
rep for galactical Smith and stuff and
what they do is they pick the hottest
girls and then guess what happens they
all know there's a shelf life
they do they know their hotness is going
to run out there's another 22 year old
that's going to take their place yeah
and stuff and it's like going and so
they try to make all their money at a
young age yeah and it's like I'm going
ladies understand that there's a shelf
like to everything that if you're going
to use your Youth and beauty that you
have a time load on yeah yeah because
once again it's like a man you know
women are born with that value yeah men
have to earn it you're saying no one you
know I I get this it was funny it's
funny because you're gonna laugh this
one so I you know went to the private
plane the other day because I like fly
private and stuff like that and so all
of a sudden it was kind of cool all the
men are like Doc that's awesome this is
this you see that one comment Miranda
you can you can look and there was a
comment going way to spend your money
during the Biden economy I looked at her
I looked at her profile some will
always fatties yes it's like because why
because you know why because you would
never be invited on there because your
Youth and beauty doesn't exist and I'm
sorry if you ever see a woman that's on
a yacht and she's good looking do you
think she got there because she earned
the money to get there
she used her value even when you think
of like female billionaires it's like
who offers more value to a society Kim
Kardashian or Elon Musk right even when
we do make money it's always monetizing
Beauty well you can think this way and
you ever see the products that that the
Kardashians use they're toxic they're
horrible they're going to make you sick
they're gonna give you cancer and all
stuff like that and all they're doing is
this different lipstick and they're just
they're doing the same thing that Mary
and all the other women did they just
threw another Beauty line yeah and then
Elon Musk is like let me continue
Humanity right like this is the level of
what we produce you know what guys talk
about when they talk about Kim
Kardashian you know they talk about they
talk about boobs and that we could set a
glass on our ass and drink from it
there you go women you want to hear what
we talk about behind closed doors it's
like we'll sit in there and go we don't
give a crap that she makes money do you
understand to a guy especially I'm
wealthy guess what happens I don't care
about a woman's money I'd never care
about a woman's money not one bit you
want you want you here it's really funny
because I do like this is is support me
do you know what I'm saying it's it and
then you'd be the greatest employee
you'd be your greatest family member
your greatest wife you get all things
that it's like support and you're not
gonna understand what I go through so
don't even question that aspect of why I
do things that way see men and that's
one thing that people realize if you
look at masculinity stop questioning us
if you have a question we'll answer it
but if your question is now you're
judging our character you don't even
know what we go through and I think
that's the big thing where it's like you
can't you tell me you can't be questions
um let me see a question how much you
worth twenty thousand dollars okay great
I'm worth over 100 million do you think
you can understand what all you go
through
see this thing it's like why don't you
ask a question maybe how I got here
because I'm proud about this the reason
why I'd like to talk about my net worth
because I started with 500 yeah
100 yeah
yeah it's like it's like but and it
wasn't feminine traits that got me where
I was
it was pure masculine traits and the Bro
mostly funny I think about the CR day
because one year ago I started a purge
started firing all the feminists and
firefighting all the women yeah but here
get this
and I've actually increased my wealth
dramatically even since then but here's
one thing about it is this way I I look
back at it and I'm like it was never a
feminine trait that got me where I was
it was a masking trade
and The Feminine parts of my company I
brought on by good feminine women not
feminists
women that once again that can relate in
Creative because I'm not creative yeah
they're creative do you saying so put
them in that position for them to
flourish a little create you got to be
creative no no what happens is this it's
here's here's where I'm creative
um
it's
I know that my career brings a better
Society yeah it brings skinnier
healthier better women out there better
men and everything so what happens is so
then what we do is you think this way it
it fills a need men are always looking
to fill a need and and that's a mask and
trait I'm sorry it's really funny I
don't have to be home every night for my
DARS to look at me like a superhero
if you it's some of the worst men that
ever worked for me their women told them
they have to be home every night for
supper and I've created something that
that got a lot of Praise but also got a
lot of criticism you know what you call
a man that's a man that's home every
night for supper broke
do you see him saying yeah broke my dad
definitely was not at home every day for
a supper thank you yeah yeah and here's
what happens this and did you criticize
him for it or what did you know your dad
was doing he wasn't sitting at the bar
he was working thank you and and and and
my daughters understood that and the
only way a daughter would resent the dad
for that is if the mom told her to yeah
that's the only way yep yeah well it's
like this watch this let's say it's um
um he also coached my basketball team
too that was my daughter's golf coach
yeah do you say yeah competition sign me
up yes but like I gotta sit and talk at
dinner no thank you I'm gonna work yes
well I got I got fired from the golf
course as a family from a feminist man
oh no way actually I think my dad got
into something I don't remember what but
there was some drama around it yes well
mine mine was a little different because
it was during coven and and of course
that's why I lost all respect for a
Christian Community because if you're a
pastor and you closed down your church
or in coveted you should not be a pastor
you should be sitting in the pews
learning some and what happens this
and I get this when Kobe came about I
contacted the Christian Schools church
ever that I said listen I will pay for
your lawyer fees if you stand up for
what's right and do right
oh no they all buckled wow and so I told
the the and he's a Headmaster for the
school and I told him I said listen I'm
sorry that you're a and you sit
down when you pee
I got fired you know what I'm saying
it's like because once again you know
love thy neighbor
you know be a Christian boy and just
conform
yeah see and that's that's how they get
and everyone it's all of them listening
to their wives We're Men thank you we're
men really afraid of covid no you know I
had I had a chick I'm not friends with
her anymore but I was friends with her
and it was so funny because she she was
like um she got really fat and I got
married but she like gained like imagine
dating wouldn't you guys feel a little
Bamboozled if you like dated a chick and
she gained like 60 pounds yeah yeah
they're like oh God please God no yeah
they're like I sign up for them like I
would take anything else anything it was
not fat
and but anyways anyways um but she she
just got married and she
she literally
um told me that like if I didn't get
vaccinated I couldn't be around her kids
and that her friends in her little
Community like like they weren't letting
their their friends see their kids if
they weren't vaccinated I mean they're
your kids to each his own but I'm like
you know the women are the ones running
everything yep and then they use the
aspect of compassion camera whichever
mostly funny is this I said this as a
man they say well my grandma's sick I
don't give a about your grandma
because you know hey Grandma guess what
happens doesn't pay our bills I would
love how it's like well just take 1800
from the government for this month you
know and and people especially the
church you went to a bunch of business
morons and stuff like that I've had I
know those guys that's why I can call
them that and stuff it's like going they
shut down they do everything that way
and it's like and um but they have no
problem taking their money on on through
the internet you know what I'm saying
it's like here but keep on supporting us
because we're doing God's work no you
don't you're actually trying to convince
me to invest with you in some cigar no
I'm sorry unless no church unless
they're pushing young marriage and
setting people up to get married and
really pushing like and real singles
event not these singles where they're
like in the middle of them dating like
saying all right that got like you two
would go well together date if it works
out it works out if it like they can't
be in the middle of it but until they're
like really pushing young marriage and
kind of shaming women for being single
like that's what we need as chicks like
to be honest like that that's something
that probably would have helped me me
when I was younger and helped like
honestly and but the problem is it's all
women they don't have any men to set
them up with because the men are like
I'm not dealing with this they
were actually single they'd rather stay
single go to work and jerk off the porn
oh yeah like what are they like there's
some there's some verse about a
quarrelson wife it's like look yeah
something I forgot what it was yeah
across some wife is is you know it's
what's the first skin it's worse than
you know it's also like that bad it's
also like it's also like a a man that
doesn't work is worse than a
non-believer well you know like men if
they get to 35 they only have like a 15
chance of ever getting married really
yeah if you make it to 35 single never
having been married
probably won't
because they're like well this juice
ain't worth the squeeze I can't blame
them nowadays I just read the numbers
and I'm like well yeah I'm like
we're 70 of us are overweight 90 of them
on birth control multiple partner it's
just like I can't even blame them let me
spin this a little bit okay okay let me
and let me let me um let me um I want
your opinion on this okay I want to see
what the other girl say in the room here
too
so
if I'm going to talk to you now granted
Justin has a very very you know
um great young lady in some of that but
I'm always and I'm and no joke just hold
you and I'm pushing him to do what guess
what I'm pushing him to do get your ass
married
dsan be a strong man do it that way do
it right do his things that don't sleep
with her until you're married no joke so
I tell these guys it's like but here's
the app is this but let's say just one
single so this happened with my doctors
this happened with my young doctors all
sudden he called me because
um he was he was pursuing his career and
he was going to move to a certain area
in the Midwest and she's like well I
want to move the white West I said then
you have to be prepared that If This
Woman's trying to move your direction
that you guys will end and she dumped
him and he called me up
set crying a little bit nice to listen I
said I'm empathetic because a guy can
have empathy putting myself in your I
can put in your shoes I said now here's
what you do and see my voice even change
I said now go out and keep on developing
your mind muscle and money
and you have women flocking to you
and I said and watch what happens and
guess what happens and don't even worry
you're you're hurting but we all hurt
you either get painted regret I said
discipline yourself through the pain of
the hurt and guess what happens because
you know it's gonna happen
number one the greatest
revenge is your success moving on oh
yeah we'll creep forever exactly
what you're doing for a lifetime exactly
and and they actually well look what
happened look what happened this Tom
Brady let's use the example before Tom
Brady did this his wife left him you say
him can you imagine and Tom Brady Tom
Brady could get a 21 year old hottie if
you wanted to now get this what do you
do wife took off he kept his mouth shut
then all of a sudden now he starts
dating even a hotter girl than her she
starts yapping like crazy because she's
what she's you know she's stalking them
she's this is like going and going so I
would tell him they'll think of this way
even at 21 years old just go develop
your mind muscle money and guess what
happens
is the world your oyster see and I
thought here's my message all the guys
if you can't find somebody that's
because you haven't developed yourself
if you develop yourself women will find
you
it's an easier time to find you than
ever it really is because like use it
flip it use media for a real thing that
way you saying because show them what
you're doing you the world has given
everybody a state now with all the media
stuff that way so it can be used for
good too yes and and on the flip side
because women are using it for their
aspect they're putting themselves out
there like crazy that's why that's why
you have every guy reached out to him
that way but it can go the other way and
so so God so I think that the fact
that's like if you have a guy right now
so you're watching right now and
you
35 and sing I'm sitting here going man
give me some time with that guy awesome
instead give me some time with that
because if you're 35 and single and
you're doing some of this there's
you I think they can develop themselves
and you can you can you can give me
opinion I think they can develop
themselves to where that they will
attract a woman to where it's like going
Hey listen but wait no she'll come no
listen here's and then you she comes to
you and say Here's my primers to be in
my life
and you choose
yes I am but you know it's really you
don't say persisto
for especially if you're a wealthy guy
it's not adaptations for people to get
married right now
no I know that's what I was gonna say
like I think there's a large group of
men that have just literally looked at
the chicks and they're like all right so
this is what I get and said you know I
don't think the juice is worth the
squeeze right so you know I think by the
time they're 35 it's kind of like they
kind of like living life on their terms
and a lot of times women come in and try
to like control men and they gotta like
think about the woman's feelings all
this stuff and they're just like eh yep
yes they would rather be without himself
but I think I think both men and women
by Nature
um if you're a guy this is me so I'm
gonna be able to be a little critical on
the guy side for a second if you're a
man of substance you want to pass your
legacy down
see that thing I want to create a so I
want to create kids in the family and
stuff of that and I'm no joke I called
Devin when we were in the car you're
saying I want to create Legacy with
four guys are going to marry my
daughters I want to create that that way
I can't I just don't want to be you know
worth a billion dollars sitting by
myself yeah do you saying because
because we have something of value to
pass down I have a question sure all
right you get two options please don't
tell me to pick a third option okay I
saw you do this on the show all the time
so I'm ready so please do not don't
don't say all right you can either be
president or with no kids
or have 15 kids with an average job I'd
be present
and that's what when guys say that like
I always think like because a lot of
time I don't think you said this in
particular but I'll hear like a guy
can't be high value if he doesn't have
kids or a legacy but I'm like what about
George Washington yeah that man has like
talked about like you know what I mean
he had no kids well there's some you
know some people say he had some love
Childs but but on paper right no kids
yep and I think as I think that God does
give gifts to certain it's a typical
yeah I believe that I've been blessed
you're saying with certain gifts so
therefore you get the best of both
worlds yes because I said I've created
something plus something I'm going to
create a Flynn Legacy that's gonna right
but the way the way some guys see it and
I'm not saying this is right or wrong
but the way some guys see it is they
don't want to risk their legacy of like
what they've built so if they've spent
like the last 10 years busting their ass
they're like you know if I if I bring in
a chick this is all risk with little
upside I can Outsource the cooking I can
Outsource and like yeah I could have can
but even if I have kids the sad part
about the legal system is when a guy has
kids they're not your kids they're hers
because if she wants to leave and take
them she can mostly funny and this is
where women in the church have really
destroyed men of today yeah is they and
they say dumb like this
women of the church WIll separate a man
from its purpose and think it's
different than him
see a man's purpose is actually number
one to him always
and they'll say no your wife and kids
are that's not really true
because they try to separate the that's
like separating that's like taking it
separate from himself that way and I
fell into that for a long time from the
church stupid thinking I used to put my
my purpose fifth I'm like no because
here's what happens this for me to even
be a great husband a great thing I have
to completely do the ant supports our
family that we need well I don't imagine
and make you resent the family like if
you're put like at least I'd imagine
like if you're if you feel like you
could be something great but your fan
like your family's supposed to support
you well sure tries to make second moms
yeah yeah be home for supper leave it to
be for all the yeah and so what
happens is and that's why then it says
all feminized that way yeah it's like
Hey listen it's like
um
and that that that's the part that I
think is so demascinating to men that
way it's like no listen just and that's
why I said I believe I can have it both
I believe that let me be my dominant
thing and then I'll create Legacy
um that's going to continue and then
I've said okay listen now I believe I
can pass on to these guys and young guys
and stuff like that that allow them to
grow and then they can see it and it's
really funny though but I always tell
people this I said but now be careful
what I teach you do you know why because
you're gonna go home and look at that
wife or that spouse differently now
and that causes problems
oh yeah it's kind of crazy when I start
to like red pill guys and like they
start to they're like yeah why am I
living for what my girlfriend wants and
I'm like you don't have to ask like like
you shouldn't have to ask permission
they're like yeah why am I like because
men are logical so like when you start
to Red Pill them on this stuff like it
makes sense like the women will have a
more visceral reaction well not all
women are like that or the matter like
oh yeah this makes perfect sense because
you can be a great man here's what
happens by Nature we you
we are drawn to do what's right yeah
yeah is the fact it's like women let me
say this here you don't have to tell
spend time with you if we don't want to
spend time with you right now there's a
reason
and if we do want to spend time with you
there's a reason and stuff you don't
have to tell us to spend time with our
kids because by Nature if you let us go
and do what we need to do and so and I
apologize even saying that if you get
the out of our way not let us do
get out of our way
no joke and I know it's going to offend
some women we say that get the hell out
of my way and let me and I didn't that's
why the fire certain women get women out
of my life yeah because I like going
get out of my way because when I when I
when you're out of my way guess what
happens everybody benefits and I've
proven that and see so I can sit there
and go I got pushed in a way that way
and that's why it's kind of funny it's
like and that's why and then that's why
your stuff caught my attention I'm like
going yeah you're you're actually
speaking what men need to hear well what
percent of men have been told your wife
should obey you yeah not when she feel
like she shouldn't like you know I
didn't even hear that until I was older
too so it's like but we haven't been
told that but it makes sense like if you
have two people that own like two can't
there's one king of a country not two if
there's a CO King like everyone Partners
at work yeah but I'm like but for some
reason we think that'll work in a
household it's like what's like every
business I own I I tell even people here
there is no democracy it's dictatorship
yeah yeah
you you could I have a board if they all
voted one way I still this and guess
what happens yeah and it's like and
there's even guys on there yeah so it's
like but the idea is this it's like
listen it's like it that you have to and
if you don't trust my leadership guess
what happens go well and as a chat like
there's even been times with my like
management team or like because
especially when hits the fair
because in media it's like you're gonna
have media circus and media storms and I
just like I'll still kind of freak out a
little bit oh my gosh like but then the
guys like Oh They'll be like I'm like oh
my gosh I'm gonna get deep platformed
I'm gonna use it because we just think
of like the work for whatever reason
women we just think of like the worst
possible scenario it's funny but I've
heard that yeah but I've just found like
I've just found that it's easier when
the guys are just like no it'll be fine
like just just say this it'll be fine
let me give you a business example yeah
the reason why I had to fire a bunch of
Boss is because what got me here
where I was today was going against the
grain and they were screaming stop being
yourself stop
I built this company without media
you're saying and so therefore it's like
but see what they do is they wanted to
preserve something instead of have
purposes and something well well women
it's like our I don't know what it is
when we get into an industry we just
police language like that's like our
specialty yeah we don't like the way you
say it like I don't know why it's just
like when we get into an industry it
just gets woke like in that's why if you
look like Christian women it's like
Jesus said the most
heinous things to their disciples but if
I say you
every Christian person is freaking out
yet they're yet they're more worried
about me saying you and and
and stuff of that than they are
about starving kids in Africa do you
saying it's like they they major in once
again women do this a lot too when
things are good they make problems oh
yeah I've seen that so much it's like I
call it Leonardo DiCaprio principle it's
the fact that you know I said just made
that up again let me explain why he's
sitting there worried about global
warming
dear sand do you really think that
people and we do know people in foreign
countries and think do you really think
they give a care about the temperature
you really care about going we can get
clean water and clean food oh I mean
like why do you think these
sell I'm like okay so let me get this
straight you gotta he wants to work yeah
I know I was like you got a handsome guy
okay so one he's handsome yeah it's
gorgeous he's he's got he's famous we
love things yes that's like the cheat
code like we just we just love like even
if you get the guy like you know it's
funny you go to the church and the
guitar players are like slaying all the
chicks in the church yeah it's like
because it's like something with a stage
we just go crazy like so so okay he's
got the fame he's handsome I'm not I
don't know if he was faithful but if
there was gonna be a celebrity like an
athlete that didn't cheat it might be
him right and I'm like but now you're
mad because he let me get this straight
like checks notes works too much yep I'm
like these chicks she was upset because
he wouldn't cover football
all these people are like going yeah
yeah he chose football as a family no
here's what happens you separate a man
from his purpose yeah you separate man
for this purpose you lose him because
sorry it's like because men ingrained I
believe you want to talk about having a
God thing inside you God puts a purpose
in every man yeah and I think a man sits
there and actually doesn't feel
connected to God because he's not living
it and then if you have women doing it's
like going get out of my freaking life
yeah it's like and that's the sad part
of this well you got a family yeah and
guess what my daughters and my family
are going to look at me like a superhero
if you just let me live in my purpose
because my DARS and they're going well
Dad's you know I'm saying it's really
funny I sat down with my daughter one
time and because I said okay listen the
girls I said day has a choice he's got
to speak a bunch and stuff of that which
is going to take me away and all these
benefits that you have from going to
Hawaii for everyone on private jets
doing all some of this would you rather
have Daddy home for supper every night
and go this the girl's like get out of
here get out of here go go to work do
you see him saying yeah no I said now
remember that do you sand yeah and it's
like I teach my married daughter say
listen I remember the same thing
because because he has a purpose and so
then you separate that from it that way
and here's here's the Christian
purpose we're there just to serve God
okay great I am serving it in my way not
your way not your way and it's like you
can just see it in a man's eyes when his
wife has just like kept him from being
who he was meant to be you can just see
it it's like this like sadness in their
eyes where they're like they couldn't
take the risk to start that business
they always wanted to start because
their wife wanted to control the money
or like like it's just like they become
like a shell of themselves I see it a
lot in the divorce documentary I'm doing
like it's just really sad yep that's
true
well because they said think about this
and let's go back to Tom Brady that way
it's like so I watched it where the
public is like and all these women even
some of the guys like yeah man you've
made your bunny you've done this do you
really think Tom Brady was doing it for
money anymore
I'm looking at him right now do you
really think I'm doing this for money
anymore
yeah I mean honestly look at my eyes do
you really think I'm doing this for
money
if it it's would be much easier for me
to just go sell the b2y and I could do
that the rest of my life and never blink
an eye do you really so that's why when
these guys were criticize in dude you've
accomplished everything you want to
accomplish that wouldn't you tell a guy
he's accomplished everything it's
Compass even as a woman to tell what the
hell do you do you're saying you're
supposed to do two things stay sexy keep
that ass tight shut your mouth
that's a joke and someone were going to
despise I said that the way it's like
going listen let him live his purpose oh
he's going eventually eventually guess
what that's it it's gonna change for him
a little bit Yeah well and you can't
have everything it's so funny because
it's like we just live in this la la
land where we think we can have
everything where it's like okay let me
get this through you want a guy that
makes a lot of money fine I don't I
don't I I don't shame anyone for wanting
what they want but you also want date
nights every week okay you also want him
to listen to all your problems like it's
kind of like okay let's pick our
poisoning like you can the same way a
guy like he can't he knows he can't get
everything he wants from a chick but
it's like women we're just told you can
have whatever you want and if he doesn't
give you whatever you want you are just
coerced and he's a narcissist right well
tell me I know that word's thrown around
a lot but I purposely don't even look at
definitions for this stuff like I don't
even know what the hell Northeast
narcissus is
you know what's funny it's so funny I
bet you more women are narcissists than
men because we're the ones obsessed with
social media okay and social media it's
like basically like you got no empathy
like you always think of yourself I
don't know the official definition it's
some some feminist wrote but
but it's essentially like you only think
of yourself and women love self-centered
men I'll say what's here let's let's
talk about this what's wrong with
selfishness because here's what happens
in men yeah because here's opposite it's
like um you know let's let's let's
appease the Christian people for a
second it doesn't say love thy neighbor
you know as you love your wife or as you
love your your friend it says you love
yourself
if you're a piece of crap you can't do
anybody any good
so guys guess what get your mind money
and muscle together and guess what
happens then you can bring on a wife and
do those things and stuff and then it's
quite interesting it's like that's the
poor boy you want me to be selfish
because me being selfish is gonna say no
I can't do this I need to do this for my
betterment which is going to make your
life better
because this whole concept they've
always because they always do this they
always twist these remember I always
love listening to Scholars and to uh
people when they talk about you know
people twist the Bible and religion for
their own ideology happens all the time
it's like because they'll take one verse
and take out the context and stuff and
they talk about well you know you know
Jesus you know he died for you're
supposed to die for your wife you're
like Jesus died for church to say okay
tell me what that means
I'm like you're right somebody walks in
I'm dying for everybody in here you're
saying just by nature but that doesn't
mean that I give up everything I do on a
daily basis to make sure that you're you
have a date night right or I give up
everything the thing it doesn't work
that way have you ever noticed how like
the Christian men will like talk like
women they do so funny it's horrible
it's so funny like when they preach
they're like like they have all these
like hot like catchphrases oh like
they'll start like the the sermon really
like soft like a chick so they'll be
like
and then they'll be like like it's like
these emotional men it's so weird and
I'm like the churches that are a bit
better are like um Latin mass Catholic
churches still have men in it and
Orthodox Churches well I say this I get
up get up and start talking to men I
I've said this before just didn't give
me a lot of fans
just like I said I I think the weakest
men sit with women on Bible studies
you wanna you because remember men teach
Bible studies and I think men but only
to men because here's what happens this
because what we talk about Behind Closed
behind closed doors is for example our
true Men issues that way and so
therefore we're gonna be like okay
listen because they're they I've always
said if you if you knew it went through
people people because it gets us wrong
people think women are more emotional
actually I believe men have greater
emotions women just have more emotions
because Men actually have more rage and
anger than women ever they do so they
have to stay stoic and they have to have
their their feelings under control
that's why you can't say to women or to
men to express your feelings hell no
because I'd get up at church and say
okay all right all you guys here how
many guys want to punch somebody and
head today
and every guy would be like you see you
come a point and it's like but you have
to be stuck and control that motion you
may saying it's like it's like in in now
if we start talking about women and what
we think go through our head every man
would raise her hand but women would be
disgusted by a win through her head
I had to disagree I disagree okay here
we go I think I think the women actually
are more violent we just can't be
because when we get the opportunity to
be more violent we are more violent I
think that I think though but don't you
think their violence is different than
the man though is because you know women
have to think of their immigration their
aggression so they do it by words
think about it you
know yes
out of three women has had an abortion
yes like we used to kill like 20 of our
kids yeah like this is the most innocent
person on the planet we just kill them I
agree you know something I'm going to
cry I'm going to correct my language on
that I'm going to say that that is kind
of true in our society today even in
Wars then when we got the power to wage
war we're like men go to war if I'm mad
I started
with articulate it a little bit better
this person we might have more emotions
I'll give you that one though and then
use those emotions that can be disrupted
that way and stuff so there we go that's
tough I just think that the reason why I
think men just have a little bit more
age raging anger because
um you're right well I guess it would be
statistically women if abortion was
considered illegal
um they would actually be in prison more
than probably men would men are more in
because of violent crimes and things
like that well you know 10 of our
ancestors were murdered but it's like
they murdered and I I wish I could I
don't know if it's 20 I could be a
little off but roughly like 20 of the
kids so I'm like it seems like we're
killing more than a minute but they're
innocent okay when men kill they do it
for a reason now I'm not always saying
it's a good reason but even like they'll
do it for like like this is a big one I
hear murderers they're like respect
respect yeah like those gangs where
they'll kill because of respect yeah so
the over disrespect right so they'll do
it like to pulled on to uphold like or
maybe like like they'll even kill a man
that they heard like touched a kid or
like you know something like that
there's actually a prison uh thing about
that that's why pedophiles are usually
killed by inmates that way well and I'll
tell you the sad thing I bet you a lot
of them are falsely accused because a
lot of women tell their kids to say that
the dad touched and this is really
common like really kind of like it I
can't even believe how many times I've
heard the same story yes yes they the
women are so socially manipulative it is
crazy like there was a story because
again Family Court there's a difference
criminal Criminal Court you need
evidence at least a lot more so than
family court it's still biased but it's
a lot harder Family Court you do not
need evidence for a guy to be guilty
that just needs to be more probable that
he did it than didn't so if a woman
starts crying he beat me like the judge
like if and they only need to sway a
judge where in Criminal Court they need
to sway a whole a whole jury right of
his peers and and in CR and family court
they don't have a right to face their
accuser right so a lot of so what will
happen is a lot of times in order to get
custody the women will tell the kids to
say that the dad touched them ruin their
whole reputation in the neighborhood
never go to Criminal Court there was a
case where a guy got his legs sawed off
yeah like these guys like went around
because they've heard he was a pedophile
they went they sawed his legs and his
arms off and then killed him wow it was
fake the woman just said like these
cases are everywhere it's so common
right and and the sad thing is like
women will do these cases face no
consequence and still get custody of the
kids right these crazy ladies
and look like oh Pearl you're just like
making this up I'm like well I can show
you court documents that's why people
when I talk about I want to talk about
things before I even I I said from my
standpoint I believe those things
because you know why because I tell
people stories about vaccine damage or
the pharmaceutical drug companies do
behind closed doors like oh oh and then
all of a sudden this last three years it
came out and like been telling you that
for years and as a content creator you
just start to see like patterns yes so
like I'll just start to like okay I'll
give you an example like when a girl
says okay I was sexually assaulted I'm
like okay what is that why don't you
tell me and usually it's not like what
they they're it's not the great I don't
know if you can say this on your channel
but it's not the rape that like we're
thinking of right it's usually like like
I said no to sex and changed my mind
later maybe you can talk to my friends
maybe he was yeah maybe he was pushy
like come on like it's like it's like
kind of like the salesman that sold the
car but the women were like kind of was
reluctantly agreed right but it's like
that's a little different but it's like
and I'll just notice or a woman that
says she was abused and I'll ask a
couple questions and be like why don't
you have permanent damage because an
average guy should be able to beat you
up and it turns out she was hitting him
or she wouldn't leave his apartment so
he kind of like threw her out of the
like out of the house and then he's like
oh he threw me across the room yeah
because you wouldn't leave you were
trespassing right but but they can call
the like and you just start to see these
like patterns where it's like all these
different people just start telling you
the same exact story and I don't believe
unless they go to Criminal Court I
just don't believe it because it's like
if they were these evil abusers these
evil rapists these evil whatever why did
why are you able to say it in family
court but you don't want him locked up
that doesn't make sense right and it's
really sad because
it's like we have this whole generation
of men that really in my opinion have
been abused by women and the legal
system backs them up well legal system
that's why people that's why I can't
laugh when they say that the United
States is a patriarchy I'm like going it
favors women in every single every way
every way I looked at going criminal I
guess what happened they get lesser
sentences uh you look at uh um divorce
Lester it's the favors of women all
things like going you know how is it
such a patriarchy just because we've
built society and actually you know we
still dominate most of the jobs that's
patriarchy I'm gonna I'm gonna read do
you remember Brock Turner a couple years
ago Robert Turner anyone Brock Turner
yes oh yes okay okay I think I think
that's was the name but yeah uh like a
ivy league swimmer was was accused he
was like yes and you know I I read
because I just start to notice like
patterns right and it's like these
really it's always based on emotions so
it's like these really like heated
campaigns where and I kind of re-looked
at the case recently and I thought he
like raped a Girl by the dumpster the
way everyone was talking about it and it
turns out like she willingly went with
him and basically these bikers pulled up
and he ran and like the idea was like
that she was blackout drunk or whatever
but so was so was he and and apparently
she kind of had a reputation around
campus but they're not even allowed to
bring the chick's reputation in court
like they can't they're literally not
allowed to say it right so I I just
start to like realize all these like
cases of these men's like lives ruined a
lot of are very over exaggerated but
there's a football punter that happened
to last year that way raise falsely
accused and he lost his job and
everything he was in training camp he
was number one puncher and stuff like
that and they realize it's false and now
he can't even get a job in the NFL
sometimes the sometimes the trial
through the process is more punishing
than the end sentence yeah because they
they all they have to do is repeat it
like well he raped person well did you
look into it well no you know what I'm
saying it's like Andrew Tate and
uh child or trafficking yeah sex
trafficking of it going uh did you read
it because well yeah when the and the
problem is what they'll do is they'll
switch that's why I say sexual assault
because basically when they couldn't get
these men for rape they added a new word
they're like let's make up a new word to
just get these men right and they added
sexual assault and sexual assault is I
can't even remember the exact definition
but it is so broad that you could put so
they make they make these either new
words or they change definitions like
for rape they used to be
um forced carnal something but like
basically for sex to sex without consent
but consent makes it subjective what is
consent if we if we're about to hook up
and then I say no no stop but like we
all know like there were movies made
about I mean what's the notebook like
the girl says no he's like I'm gonna
jump off of this Ferris wheel if you
don't go on a date with me yeah and
we'll always like push but like in and
so then it becomes subjective right and
that's what they do it's like they add
in these words they change the
definition to just put men in jail yeah
talk about patterns I've seen this now
and I think that's why you see more men
being single
um there's a pendulum swing there is
it's like you're seeing you're seeing
women have such power today that men are
just like I'm checking out I'm checking
out from families I'm checking out from
this way and then what's going to happen
is this is but you're going to have
you're going to have men like me that
push back and you're going to be like
uh-uh you want to compete in this world
let's go
do you say I'm and you're not going to
win because a true competitive man will
not back down and some of that and
you'll sit there and fight for what's
right and I think that's where and I
think that's why you know demasculating
true masculine men that are trying to
create a good Society stuff of that have
to be demonized yeah and stuff and they
have to be marginalized and they have to
create terms they have to create you
know it's like Robert F Kennedy Jr you
know he was he he investigated things
and he realized that vaccines have
caused a lot of damage on top of it he
said okay listen he said there's no
science you're lying to everybody so
that's great terms like anti-vaxxer
you're saying to label people to in
order to do it that way and stuff and
it's like going and I kind of laugh like
going but uh I think you're I think it's
a great opportunity now for
because you talk about because like I
said be believing in God believe it in
Jesus I believe that guess what happens
that God put that inside of certain
people and that's why I don't believe
that everybody I believe that everybody
should have equal rights but I believe
everybody's equal do you say I always
tell by doctors you're not equal to me
do you know why you didn't go through
what I had to go through to get here
yeah you ever think about how the
Constitution is kind of woke
um all men were created equal right and
that's the part that's one part you
don't have a problem with because I
don't think they were no I don't think
so either I I wasn't created equal
career to everybody else because
otherwise everybody do what I do and
everybody would actually be able to
tolerate the things that now I I do
believe that um that men inside them
have more than what their dads in the
society is asking for them and I think
that's why
um and I think that it's really
interesting and then I think that has to
be pulled out and I think you're right I
think that uh women has have done a
really horrible job especially the
especially the churches have done a
really horrible job instead of
developing men they started to become
more woke so therefore guess weapons
than men have just decided but but then
what happens this I say they're going
guys this is your great opportunity to
step up because you'll stick out like a
sore thumb
you understand to be a masculine man no
you stick out and all the women are
drawn to it so as we tell guys I'm like
you're single this this go be a man
that's what women are actually truly
looking for and stuff and uh um it's
gonna be interesting yeah you're right I
always said I think what they're talking
about because I do love politics I do
love history they're talking about that
we are treated the same that we have
under the law or equal that means for
example that no one's have favor even
though our policies and skirt that
because why isn't Harvey's uh weinsteins
or why isn't um what's the guy that got
killed in New York Epstein do you have
Epstein why is the list let go oh yeah
it's like there's there's bad
individuals why didn't the list let go
why these things go on it's like and
we're all the good men stepping up
saying
you know let's do this it's really funny
I talked to me and Travis were in
Florida and we talked this marine and he
was you know we're just talking about
some certain things and double politics
and things like that and he's like he
goes I think the Resurrection the
interaction was horrible and things that
I looked up and said what are you
talking about
it's like do you understand that that uh
um when men have when when when all of a
sudden that these politicians stuff have
power without respect and fear they're
not going to do what's right and so they
that people got fed up and I think
that's important that what happens is
right now that men need to get fed up
with all these and all the feminists and
all the over spiritualized that
Christian women are bringing in some of
that that what happens is this I think
it's so I said to tell young men to tell
them and it's the greatest opportunity
right now in the world to step up and be
masculine and watch yourself thrive
and I think that's uh and it it you know
so you know what really saddens me I
like this but I hate this it saddens me
that that uh that your channel actually
is the one that had to do it instead of
other men
Tina sand yeah it's like and I think I
think but I also think the fact that you
give men some hope going yeah you know
something is this you know sometimes
hearing it from a little different
perspective is is important and stuff
like that well I also think that you I'm
a way to get I think I'm Shadow
vandalous because I'm a chick yeah you
know well if I say it remember but see
but I will say this I did a poll I did a
poll called should women think and most
men said most people no but get this you
know what's like funny do you know why I
can get away with a lot of stuff yeah do
you understand this is not a joke
and I try to tell men this you know now
how hot you know how not to worry about
Society have money
yeah because you know why
I was kicked off YouTube Facebook and
also this
and I still did this
because I create my own network then my
own channel yeah and then all the people
came there they're going do you
understand that that's what people are
like they're going to find you yeah the
people are that when they look for up
they're going to find you yeah and so I
just said so I said you guys have to see
I understand for the this is where I
where or the you know you you get stuck
within society and and you have to
accept stuff like this when you don't
have Financial Freedom to tell people to
piss off
and see that's why you think a lot of
people won't say stuff on YouTube
because worry about demonetization and
get kicked off I might go on okay I saw
it coming no joke I asked my team I saw
this coming before when Kobe sorry I
said guys we need to actually put our
own platform because they're going to
they're going to kick us off and I saw
it coming I could that's one thing I can
say I predict a lot of things and so I
saw something we produce our own our own
network our own channel to this and I
started Purdue I started doing
everything through there which I control
I have my own servers I have everything
that way so kick me off okay and when I
did get kicked off YouTube and Facebook
that way I just moved to my website that
way and I have and I control it and
stuff of that and so it's like so I
think it's a great opportunity for
everybody that's listening to your
channel and they stuff take it seriously
and then start taking the steps because
but you know some of this I think that
they don't want to tackle those hard
things they can't start with their own
personal life and look at people
um that they may care about yourself
that and say you're wrong no
which once again is extremely tough for
most people but what's tougher I'm sorry
the world today sucks to live in
it really does yeah because I think I
think like one of the greatest lies is
that this is the best time to be alive
I would happen to read with you on that
like I don't know I I've read about
different time periods where like
everybody had their own piece of lit
like I was like Wow and they like they
had like six kids each like now you know
and and I think like now we have all
these people a group in single mother
homes all these mental issues well even
when they when they want to yell about
slavery do you understand that what
happens this there was times you know
not even 60 70 years ago that
um it doesn't matter African-American or
white they were still married they still
had families they have stuff like this
and now it's like now guess what happens
you have the least ever things happen in
history and guess what happens they're
complaining the most it's like it's like
oh my goodness you know but see that's
why I think that that the fact that
we've lost hierarchies we've lost that
there's a leader in every household we
lost at their sleep it's really funny
and it's no different than this
employees today
actually think they're just as important
as CEO
[Laughter]
sorry it's like you don't if you want to
do what I do then go through a
sacrifices yeah only women are that
delusional I would you know something I
would agree with you on that because
what happens is this is like uh and and
the gender pay Gap is the uh
the the gender created or gender is a
society contract is bullcrap it's like
it's like no no listen it's biological I
can even tell heck I showed you a lab
today where they're changing the biology
of of men to women it's hurting them
physically mentally yeah I showed you
Labs about that today
a transgender person that way it's like
and we accept this you know it's really
funny those and yet it's really
hilarious everybody everybody uh you
know uh hails on or you know yells about
Putin well look we just did he said
listen none of this crap here
I'm asking do you see the funny I saw
the funniest clip the other day this um
this lgbtq chick asks this African
president about like meeting with him
about their rights and he just starts
laughing he's like no yeah I did see
that we are not doing that he's like in
this country no it was fantastic what's
wrong with telling people no
and um it's like no and see what they
did and I yelled about this long time
ago oh we just want to marry the person
I marry I said that's where that's where
it all starts it starts with just a
little foot in the door and it's like I
just want to love what I love I want the
same rights as Christian people getting
so on Mary I was like no it's not simple
no you know I'm saying and then because
you know why because now it's like it
turned to now you have to accept this
way and you better if you teach against
it with a Cancer and now what happens is
you're not even forget you know L and G
on all the alphabet they stole and some
of that but they go hey guess what
happens this now you have to accept that
guess what that your kid
not even a real female
am I going this is the digitality that's
why you go to Dubai that's that's why
that's why it's very funny we're all the
Christian people they have to putting up
gay pride Flakes and stuff like that and
people say this people say well you know
you don't really care what people do yes
I do because you know why because when
you do something it's like this it's
like people say you know people should
have you know just if they choose to
vaccinate this well no if you just used
your choice and kept your mouth shut
cool but you try to force your lifestyle
on us that's the thing I want straight
pride month yes yeah I want very proud I
also want you know just since we're like
talking about things I want I want a
month dedicated to gingers yeah that's a
very rare we're the biggest minority it
doesn't I'm like why can't I get I can't
get a ginger pride and blue and green
eyes where the ginger is even more rare
yeah well I have green eyes that's right
that's I'm the second rarest combination
yes it's true it's like because you are
a minority yeah I that's what I say you
know it's really funny watch this until
kova you know who the most discriminated
people on the planet were you know
people who hated vaccines
oh yeah vaccines is the biggest
religion in the world wow that's what
that's why there's that's why it's
trillion people tear on gas and
militaries of that do you understand the
medical field is the biggest Mafia in
history it was proven over the last
three years wow
oh my gosh do you see how they wouldn't
debate that one like one guy on Twitter
was like
I forgot how many of millions of dollars
put in I I actually donate 50 grand for
that so I'll put 50 grand out there for
it I was like going in a bunch of tape
with half a million yeah they put 100
000 it was like I'm like good I'll put
50 Grand in so that's like but see
that's the thing they try to stop a
discussion and like I said and don't
tell me about being an expert look how
the experts here if medical system was
so right why are people so unhealthy
you know do you understand that the
medical field in the well in the weather
channel is only two people are wrong all
the time people go back yeah for advice
I mean I was even I was even talking to
you I'm like I've been sick since I was
like forever like you've seen doctor's
life yeah I was like I've been I've been
like getting sick every winter like I
would just get sick it's like every
winner I think I think one of the
stupidest things for men especially is
counseling
it is and it was going I'm like what the
hell is a counselor gonna tell me oh and
I I know the funny thing is I studied
psychology in England I dropped out
because I honestly just picked it
because it was like it was like really
cheap with the volleyball program I did
and I kind of wanted something easy so
it's like psychology and
um yeah and I went into it and I really
realized I was like all these chicks
good that are going to be psychologists
or batshit Crazy by far they're like
insane do you understand it's one of the
most corrupt parts of medicine because
you're laughing this all they have to do
if you think of this way they have to
they label you as psychologically off
and then do you understand there's no
criteria for drugs when it comes to
psychology zero none yeah yeah when the
major negative side effects of every
psychiatric drug is suicide
and they don't even understand how they
really work
but no seriously it's I believe that
like like and it's a female-led
relationship because no man is like
honey I really just want to go to
couples counselors like no man is saying
that that's a chick that's a chick drag
in your ass well because what they what
they want to do is they want them to see
it always from the female standpoint
yeah what was seeing it from ours
and honestly the only psychologist I've
seen that are good are men because like
when
we don't like one of the people we'll
just take the other side like a person
absolutely uh like uh but like I said
you wouldn't even considered that kind
of counseling is Jordan Peterson do you
saying he's like get up and be a man get
up and do your stuff yeah and stuff
that's like it's like you're right
become best version of yourself yeah
it's like and and then get people now
I'll tell you this to every Atlanta get
anybody out of your life that's trying
to stop you becoming the best version of
you I don't care if it's your mother I
don't care if it's your wife I don't
care if it's your best friend I don't
care get him out of your life because
once again you talk about they take you
away from your purpose they take away
from what you're meant to be that way
but as it happens you'll end up
presenting them do you say them and then
the worst case thing you can ever do
it's like I said do not trust guys that
surround themselves with girls for
advice
because they will tell the guy he's
always good enough and I'll tell you
right now it's like if you're always
growing you don't want to hear you're
always good enough you want to put
yourself through pain to get better and
stuff and so it's like yeah so well
Pearl oh my goodness I realize it's been
three hours
[Laughter]
if you get two talkers on a podcast yes
um where can all of my audience find you
follow you
um leave comments watch a show and stuff
like that where give it gives every
possible place that we can find you yeah
YouTube it's just juggly things or
pearls should come up
um pearly things with a Z on Twitter
um I'm on Tick Tock I don't know they
just post clips for me on there and
Instagram uh just pearly things won
because they deleted my first one so
that's everything yes yes it's kind of
great and so
um please do me a favor like I said uh
get no pearl over the last six months
has been great please encourage her to
continue now you sugar
that's great but we ate at my restaurant
today I gave her one of our favorite
things which is a caramel salted caramel
latte today and stuff and and uh she's
seeing how health food can be so good
for you and oh my gosh it was so good I
can't even I was shocked I was like this
is gonna suck there's no sugar in it it
was actually amazing good good good and
I said because that's so I'm in I'm in
uh uh Pearl's life trying to give her
good health advice because I want her to
be healthy happy and actually continue
her work that she's doing and stuff like
that so it's uh it's been a absolute
pleasure getting to know you and some of
that I'm very happy that the audience
that we have all over the world is going
to know who you are and stuff and so
we're looking forward to uh having you
back too and I can't wait to move to
Chicago yeah because you'll be a little
closer and things like that and uh um
it's exciting to watch your channel grow
and continue all the great interviews
and and uh um I said it's uh it's been
fun so thank you so much for being on
today yeah thanks for having me this has
been so fun awesome